one and a two and a three tweeting It
Out friends and neighbors of the reject
Nation let us know if we are live this
is the part where where you tell us you
are the most crucial part of the
beginning of this live stream so
sound off in the comments let us know
that we're live and leave a like my name
is John this is Greg Alva the realist
reject and of course koi genre the comic
bookiest comic book to ever comic book
yay we are here to discuss the Black
Panther wakanda most always Sean does
more intros I like his intros so guys uh
leave down in the comments what you guys
thought of black panther wakanda forever
uh we saw it again
just last night
as well yeah did you see on IMAX I did
first viewing freaking beautiful and I'm
stunning it's beautiful people I see
some people on Twitter like talking
about how AMC has this weird lighting
issue and I've experienced that with
them and Cinemark but IMAX they're
pretty good yeah I I know she's an IMAX
stop to your quality when you get the
best screen you spend 27 oh boy is it 27
we're gonna keep one screen bright
enough AMC A-list however exceptional
value bring back the OG logo the logo
changes like every two years so don't
worry which one is it which one's your
OG logo in five to ten Years it'll be
time to go retro and then the OT logo
I've seen nothing but praise on the new
logo
um Sleek yeah it's nice but yeah it was
a good call but what do you got put down
in the comments uh eight one out of ten
one to ten what would you rank black
panther wakanda forever also before
everyone gets into it because I see many
comments already jacket is from
boxlunchgifts.com check out box lunch
every ten dollars you spend do you feed
someone they give a meal for every ten
dollars you spend so they're an
incredible company incredible fandom
actually good people and uh that's where
this jacket's from box lunch check them
out and uh we're drinking well the boys
here are drinking G fuel I made sure to
hook them up G fuel
go save yourself 20 yeah look at the
plugs away at the top of the show find
the links that are not in the
description box
we just actually used them all right so
it looks like uh going through the
comments here everything's at least uh
on average above an eight here for you
guys
um about eights nines and tens yeah it's
a good amount of people all right eight
through ten eight through ten okay well
there's a lot of spoiler details to get
in through so that if you guys didn't
catch the memo it is a spoiler talk so
after seeing it twice I will say that
like I was after the first time watching
it was definitely in in massive awe uh
over the film and I still loved it the
second time around but I did find some
problems uh that I was like oh yeah I I
didn't this wasn't like a just stating
or long lasting feeling after the movie
was done the first time I watched it and
it just stood out to me more because I
was on a second go around so I was like
all right let's put a little bit more of
a critical eye on and there's like it
did not change my opinion I still love
the hell out of this movie
um but I I do find that they're like
yeah I want to talk about like the ever
raw storyline some of the qualms that
I've heard about Riri Williams of course
gotta talk about killmonger appearing in
here the Civil War parallels there's a
lot to get into on this particular uh
review here so here we are right now
um then the D that then the dude drops a
two after they say that what does that
mean someone we said it's an average of
an eight so someone was contrarian
because we're on the internet yeah you
gotta love the contrary yeah they're
just like ah contrarian they meant they
had a one they just messed up uh yeah so
koi what would you say what I want you
to describe really fast is you had
issues with no more I did I have uh
issues and you didn't really get a
chance to go too deep into that what was
true so I basically uh it's funny I went
the other way uh my first viewing is
more critical and then the second
viewing I tried to like let go of the
steering wheel a bit so uh it's
somewhere between a four and a four and
a half star film for me and the four out
of ten right out of ten forty percent
like that guy with the two
um no but it's uh it's between a four
and a four and a half star film for me
and it depends on how I feel about no
more because no more is the villain of
the story but at no point and and I love
when a villain is sympathetic and I love
when you understand the perspective of
the villain and I don't like mustache
twirling villains that being said I have
to process whether or not the
characterization of no more felt
authentic to what I perceived the
character as in a way that I don't feel
hypocritical because I often uh discuss
how much I love Zack Snyder's view of
what Heroes can be and the gods above us
and in his entire universe and that that
very tangible world he built but I often
then say I don't see his Superman how I
see Superman I don't see his Batman how
I see Batman so I'd be a hypocrite if I
didn't do that for every property my
issue with the more is I've always seen
him as arrogance first the first thing I
think of when I think of Namor is
arrogance I think of a man who thinks
himself more than he is even though he's
already a king and a God and that's kind
of the point is he's already nine
pactastic God of Atlantis seen as all
this but he always thinks he's even more
than that he thinks he can take out all
the Avengers sometimes he can he thinks
he can do all these things I never felt
any arrogance from no more like I would
have Namor I felt confidence and also he
was hospitable dude like welcome people
back gave a tour I don't see Namor like
bopping around with shuri and having
that kind of
relationship because if that is the way
it stays when Sue storm has a crush on
him instead of her absent-minded genius
but curmudgeon husband I'd be like well
you should probably hit the nice guy and
namora was a nice guy and to the point
where I understood his perspective he
just had to act first he felt that in
defending his kingdom he was the one
that had to strike first in order to
protect things he was invaded he was
exposed he had to set a precedent every
decision he made was to protect his
people and there was no shred of it
being about him to the point where at
the end of the movie the very last scene
was him defending his actions with
plausible thought as opposed to I'm
Namor like it just didn't feel like the
character to me but all of that being
said it was the exact exact right
characterization for the movie it is
exactly the villain wakanda forever
needed and is the exact type of villain
the sequel to Black Panther needed it's
the exact type of villain this movie
with these characters needed to tell
their story so when I'm thinking it's a
four and a half our film it's when I'm
completely thinking of it as a film when
it drops down to a four for me it's when
I'm going okay but at what point does
the character exist in name only and
that's my issue fair enough
fair enough nuanced criticism I I feel
like there's there's I I do think he is
um quite stubborn though
stubborn Maybe not maybe not complete
arrogance but I think he's incredibly
stubborn like he's been down there for a
very very long time and he's like no no
no no this is the way it has to go and
on top of that too
um I think when he's showing because on
my rear watch I was like this I remember
feeling like this is a look coming along
a little fast when he is like hey Sherry
here's my whole backstory right
um and while I like the backstory and I
think thematically really works and
overall I enjoy it I do think it like
kind of comes fast but in the end the
movie in the back revealing and taking
her on a tour made more sense to me
because of the fact that he is trying to
create an alliance with her and create a
type of sympathetic approach that way he
can ultimately he's trying to get shuri
to side with him and that's the reason
why he's showing her around I always
felt Neymar would be like hey this is my
Arby you're listening to me sure but I
think I think this is more interesting
though that's that's why it works for
the movie it comes through the character
it's kind of like Thanos in in when I
read Thanos he's usually just like I'm
the man
but then you watch an Infinity war and
he's kind of like calm and cold and
calculated you know so I think having a
bit of a different approach we've got
some super chats I would like to like
hop into but no I think I think it's
fair to have those points that's just so
that's my biggest problem and I like uh
being able to be like yeah for me all
the time yes but did you guys like
nemour one of the few times I disagree
with koi oh my God you got some Coy
disagreements in here that's inevitable
and what happened to the most about it
start the koi hate it starts here yeah
supposed to chill Justice for Neymar
someone in the chat was saying let the
other guy speak you asked for the
in-depth answer and I wanted them I
wasn't bow guarding
you guys know how we I I do believe that
that koi is uh he's entitled to his
opinion and I I don't feel the way koi
feels I know John probably doesn't feel
the way he uh you've I don't like
Hispanic people well that might affect
your experience this might be a
difference and black panther made me
like black people what do you know hey
it's kind of just crazy you know there
we go we've taken the hate off koi with
satire just races that's right man one
leads to the other damn uh Nash Nash
sonadiki how's it going buddy thank you
for the super thank you sorry sorry yes
no to be serious though I I uh both
times really loved uh the portrayal of
Namor but I completely respect the
argument about Spirit of a character
versus execution and uh yeah I can't
take that from anybody yeah yeah and uh
yeah no I I I I feel like it it's one
thing for me to like yell at koi and be
like it's not the same thing but I also
know what it's like to be in koi's
position but I really have a clear
perspective on who he was I don't think
of being unreasonable yeah he was an
exceptional cuckoo con yeah like I get
10 out of 10 cuckoo con yeah and that
was the great villain for the movie
yeah uh all right nationality sorry Val
scene felt last minute to promote secret
Invasion to explain why Ross is on the
run in the trailer for secret Invasion
yeah uh on my I I didn't I wasn't really
dissecting it because I was kind of just
waiting to see where it panned out the
first time I watched it and it wasn't
really my lasting impression thinking
about the scenes in it because it's only
like 10 minutes of the movie really the
stuff with Martin Freeman and Julia
Louis-Dreyfus it's not that long
although I when I do watch it the second
time I'm like oh yeah this [ __ ] is most
of it is really unnecessary in terms of
moving the plot forward like I think
there's a thematic thing they're trying
to touch on because I know it's
something you really liked about it with
um uh you know the idea that like
America's just on the sidelines being
like we should probably do something
right like because killmonger is the
American perspective so I like that it's
like let's see how this all plays out
and then we'll take the stuff I think
there's an idea there but nothing really
Becomes of it other than let's set up
Martin Freeman to appear you're in
secret information you know like if you
really think about it that doesn't
really do anything that the actual plot
nothing happens from that I think it
gives outside wakanda and telokan Stakes
I think it allows for it to feel like a
global threat versus like the UN scene
if it ended right there it'd be like
wait we're not going back to that giant
giant setup and instead it gives us a
character we've met in the first film it
gives us a character we are already
endeared to to establish the stakes
being Global to me you hear this guy
doesn't like them more that much but it
can totally get on board with this point
greatly by undressing the worldwide
phenomenon of War I think it makes sense
to have that plot thread as a part of
everything going on however yes if you
look at the movie comprehensively it is
the thing you could remove the most
easily without enacting any kind of
change for the most part except for how
they find out who the scientist yeah I
mean I liked I think the one scene that
was truly necessary because I think if
they had sacrificed that screen time and
given something which I will go into
later than given something to Riri
Williams instead another scene for her
then I think the issue that people have
with saying that ReRe feels more like a
setup for Iron Heart than feeling
necessary there's one scene I think they
could have given a Riri instead for that
screen time that would have made that
feel that package feel more complete
yeah
um olente well thank you Nash thank you
for thank you to anyone who contributes
to the super chassis stream lamps by the
way that means the means a lot thank you
are we still live John yeah we are okay
cool
um
olenty
um missing the live to watch BP the
second time 10 out of 10. I'm glad to
hear you go watch Black Panther wakanda
forever the second time appreciate your
support contribute to the flim industry
Nash
um uh John why don't you read it I
wanted Neymar Namor or Namor however you
prefer to yell save Martha in that
moment and I think that would have been
the most uh you know the the best call I
think that would have been subtle and a
good Olive Branch extension for the
inevitable cross so you know what Andrew
Gordon our friend and uh family member
of the real rejects pointed out to me is
that the true connective tissue of both
universes is Anderson Cooper he's in
both universes and thus that's how we
get there that's how we cross the road
the amalgam universe is Anderson
Cooper's beautiful hair that's right he
just Clips it on every minute the last
Targaryen Anderson Cooper I did live I
did love that moment a lot and uh like
Andrew was reminding us yesterday of how
that really does mirror um t'challa in
Civil War when um he decides ultimately
not to kill uh Baron Zemo it's a it's a
great mirroring I also just like when we
have the global impact like right that
to me I like when Marvel feels like it
it affects more than just sure that's
why I think I like the Martin Freeman
stuff so much kind of it doesn't
actually affect anything other than hey
let's just discuss maybe doing something
Richard ship from The West Wing and
Richard
schiffs I think that whole scene at the
U.N is necessary to set up the of when
they do
um uh go into the telecon waters and
then they have the vibranium and then
the follow-up scene I'm talking about as
if in the in the four of them in the
room and they're like well I don't think
you should made him condoms
nothing happens we have the impending
pending in Time Bomb of maybe a third
literally amounts to nothing he doesn't
even know what scene you're talking
about I can't tell you oh we're there in
the kitchen
the one in the one that's filmed in the
Boston police uh station that they
called the the Langley where they like
zoom in and like their four of them are
sitting in a room oh yeah Richard Schiff
is like I think we should have paid
wakanda Martin's like I know the
wakanda's you don't mess with the conda
jewelry Drive is like I'm playing both
sides he's the expert it could have been
canned it would not have changed the
movie at all
for the next Super Chat before the next
Super Chat we need to do a Quick Drip
check uh because Julian T says koi the
jacket is everything where did you get
it and I want to know where you got it
uh this jacket is from box lunch uh if
you go to boxlunchgifts.com they donate
10 every 10 you spend they donate a meal
to people in need so you're literally
helping feed people that need it most
and it's a authentic uh fandom and it's
branded so it's like quality I I love
box on so much and you can get it there
humanitarian drip Ben Rafferty no we did
not do panda did not do pandemic Jones I
am a jerk especially to our beloved
patrons what's more arrogant than people
than a man wanting to invade the whole
world a man that feels like he's
defensively challenged to because he's
three quarters of the world and the
surface people have done nothing really
been challenged he lost his entire home
it's been many years
um
let's see uh no it mocks we will talk
about that scene I promise you uh which
is the scene in uh read the live chat
this human sure he's going through
telecon I really want to talk about that
pandemic Jones phenomenal movie I loved
it more the second time I could talk
about it four hours second viewing I
noticed that Naki and tachella's Son
greets Queen raimondus when she goes to
Haiti hope you all are doing well that's
a really good catch what I noticed on
the second time watching it was when
they're at the river when they want to
burn the road when uh Ramona wants to
burn the robes and sure doesn't want to
before Namor shows up she's about to
tell her yeah
she's like well actually t'challa oh I
need to tell you something about your
brother and yeah the second viewing
gives you so many great plants for her
knowing and I loved how the speaking to
what pandemic Jones is saying is how uh
casual he was towards the queen and it
showed their relationship like yes he
approached her like they knew each other
and you don't realize that until the
second viewing that that's it this is
his granddaughter yeah exactly exactly
she should be a pretty recognizable face
all all the children of Haiti would know
who Queen remember I mean obviously
they all watch the television
Angela Bassett probably also exists in
the universe so they just think it's her
it's just actress Angela Ben Rafferty
you want to read it uh might not be top
five movie for me however I think its
ending is arguably the best ending of an
MCU movie to date and beautifully done
there's a certain uh video on this very
Channel you should watch starring Greg
and myself discussing this exact thing I
think it is an Immaculate ending and I
loved watching it with a because we saw
it on IMAX yesterday and we I was at the
very very top row so I just kind of took
the moment to look around and just take
it everyone who's like crying yeah at
that seat and like you know you see
people who are leaving at right when the
credits roll and you're like what a
bunch of idiots like come on you know
the game by this point don't you you saw
any movies
you know the game you stick around and
it communicates differently for this one
because this time you're not like but
you need to know what the next Easter is
like no no like the the emotional rap of
the story hasn't concluded entirely yet
like don't Rob yourself it only gets
more painful in 12 seconds stable right
but that's that's that is something I
appreciate is like not to not to be a
Scorsese or whoever else Christopher
Nolan the most recent person bitching
about the MCU but like it is one of the
MCU movies that ends the most like an
actual movie yeah like a real emotional
story I personally love that they didn't
do any sort of Doctor Doom post-credits
scene I I think that it would have felt
like here's a rotten
always go for this oh let's go for the
Doom always go first there was a mutant
in the movie how many videos have I made
about doom and I'm saying it would have
felt like a commercial like they gave us
an emotional resonant ending instead of
giving us a commercial for the next
thing and I respect that yeah no I I
agree with you man I agree with you I
love commercials I I I remember the
first time watching it going this would
feel really inappropriate if Dr Doom
suddenly showed up in this film yeah if
there was a a scene at the very end that
wasn't somehow let's write into the fire
on top of
can we uh take a second to put those
super chats away I do want to
acknowledge this um so uh yesterday I
this was the first thing I woke up to it
was the literally the first thing I woke
up to and
um I wanted to like say something quick
on YouTube about it but I just chose not
to and I did talk with some people about
it uh Kevin Conroy voice actor for you
know Batman the Animated Series the
Batman games made of the DC animated
movies uh you know like I I grew up on
Batman the Animated Series played the
games and if like all those things and
I've never been so I don't want to make
this about me I will just say like I've
it's my first time ever where a voice
actor has passed away where I was like
wow I'm really
I'm really hit by this this is really
devastating it's always sad if you hear
about someone passing away but but this
is this hit me on a different level and
I think for a lot of people it did as
well you know like all of us grew up
watching Batman the Animated Series oh
yeah and stuff and he is the voice and
the many would argue that he as a matter
of fact like a month ago I was watching
Kevin Smith's ranking of the best Batman
and he put uh Kevin Conroy as his
favorite and I heard so I'm like yeah
you know he might just be the best one
and he's just he had the perfect balance
and uh he died it pretty 66 that's
pretty yeah that's too early to go
it is one of those things where you just
don't expect it and uh even when he came
out on crisis on infinite Earths as live
action Bruce Wayne I thought he did an
excellent job I was like holy [ __ ] he
could be like Batman Beyond Batman yeah
like live action version and he was in
the show I'm just saying that uh he
could be like that in in a live action
form and so uh yeah I just wanted to say
uh rest in peace to uh the greatest
Batman voice actor that and possibly the
best Batman that's ever existed I I do
love the universal respect and
admiration of everyone with this this
lost where there is this Collective like
it's not like James Bond where you've
got everyone's got their favorite James
Bond like there's as many Batmans and I
feel like everyone's like Kevin Conroy
comma pick your Batman there's always
that like he's and what I love about him
so much is that there was always a very
strong awareness of what he meant to
people and what we meant to him like
he's one of those people that goes to
Khan's constantly and and is just in the
fans and having that like moment of like
sharing the love of the character with
him he never seemed like I'm over here
as Batman and you're over there as fans
like I want to be with you and and I
just love
um that we live in a time where he got
to know how much we loved him yeah and
that's not uh not everyone gets that so
I'm at least glad that the the Silver
Lining is that man knew he was loved and
he knew what he meant to us and I'm at
least happy for that he made a massive
impact so yeah rest in peace Kevin
Conroy you were phenomenal
and we know a lot of voice over actors
you know and so I see it in the
community uh I was like wow this is
really it's a ripple I've never seen it
quite happen before uh in my personal
experience I I haven't so yeah rest in
peace Kevin Conroy
anyway Let's uh transition back to
that's really a happy movie it's gonna
be a great thing but I did want to take
a second and talk about that you know
it's in the spirit of mourning yeah
certainly
um all right thank you Janine Janine
Janine the machine in the chat yes
fellow schmoe
um yes or and that's the other thing
like what Cena's pointing out in the
chat and then we'll move back to Black
Panther is that there are some people
who didn't grow up on the Animated
Series but grew up on the games and
that's another thing that made Kevin
Conroy so unique was he was decades you
know of this guy in different iterations
of Batman but kept that the thing that
was constant was his performance yeah
you know like he could be in the
Animated Series he could be in in one of
the random movies he could be in the
games and that's how many people a lot
of people were not introduced to him via
the Animated Series you know and I love
that he's every medium's potential
Batman yeah he just has that he's got
the oh man he's a perfect blend of Bruce
and Batman oh yeah well and yeah and
like Janine pointed out it's like having
the the two voices distinct and also
just the way in which it's adaptable
between media you know it's like you
have your quintessential Batman animated
series but then the way it morphs
depending on if it's a game or whatever
else
I was watching I saw Kevin Smith
reposted that clip of him in what is it
yoga hosers it's just tickled me so much
because like he's also I think an
underrated just actor in general and the
way that that scene plays out where like
he's trying to buy the cigarettes and
then you know they mouth off to him and
his demeanor just changes and he's like
let's go Robin
it's just like a perfect weird little
meta yeah I'm trying to see this time
stamp thing there she's trying to make
trying to make chapters to put in later
trying to think ahead here anyway we got
some more Super attachments
yeah I just want to make like that way
for playback people can hop around later
on beautiful uh do you want to refresh
that one last time John
what did you buy doe eyes how about my
man killmonger the killmonger scene was
great I guessed because it was that it
was one of those moments where you're
like are they gonna do something [ __ ]
you know dude I feel like the whole
theater collection he's still here
don't do it um and and then when
um and then when he did appear it was
like okay I mean yeah you would have to
have him appear because you can't get
Chadwick Bozeman to do it but the way
they used killmonger specifically for a
narrative purpose to improve Sherry's
story I was like oh my God genius use of
it and uh he just slips right back and I
roll that rank were those stages were
films together those guys have done yeah
I love that he's the good luck charm
yeah I also like I love that uh the
stages of grief are so clearly
represented by different people right
you got like acceptance uh with Angela
Bassett you've got you know the anger
with him and we need to see her go
through all that and I love that we get
personifications of it to add to the
visual nature of the movie making yeah
and I love that he got to be that and
you know him and Chadbrook were such
good friends I'm really glad that you
know he got to be in this movie that
that felt right no amazing it was an
amazing standout scene
all right let's go back to here uh Jay
all right so this conversation is going
to be
um uh about you know uh hopping between
why koi loves Martin Freeman and Julie
we're driving since movie and why we
don't oh yeah and and my hatred
foreign
it's a hatred Oreo yeah yeah yeah with a
loving cream in the middle the whiteness
of Martin Freeman in the middle is that
what you're saying Jay says uh I get koi
but I thought he was pretty arrogant
it's just a manipulative disguised his
arrogance see that's the thing is uh I I
would actually have to agree is that the
way he was going about it like while he
was justified in his motivation that
doesn't negate the fact that there was
that arrogance of the fact that he just
refused like the whole thing I remember
the first time watching it be like Jesus
Christ man let this whole thing
it did feel that way like come on come
to seriously like Let It Go and to the
point where yeah like he was not he was
so desperate to be understood but the
last thing he was willing to do was
understand them
and understand someone else's
perspective while even sure he was
trying to understand it really was
making the effort no more just would not
understand and that's part of his Arc is
that he does understand in the end is it
having an arrogance of attitude like I
see myself as this lofty God rather I
think that's part of it I think it's all
useful in this movie yeah should he be
boastful is that the thing yeah I also
felt like he genuinely listened to all
of his underlings like I felt like he
listened to his two generals and to like
the people and I don't feel like Neymar
does that I feel like does that but I
feel like there's no way that he would
take anyone else's advice in in the
personification of how I perceive him
because that's how he loses so many
fights the only way to beat Neymar is by
convincing him of his own like Folly and
like this dude like you need to trick
Neymar into winning because he is as
strong as the Hulk this guy is like
listening to you okay
um
interesting
[Laughter]
[Applause]
um I was I did have a quick question to
pose uh that was more related to the the
killmonger and Ryan coogler uh do you
think Ryan coogler will return to the
MCU
uh maybe I'll just give some time I want
Ryan coogler to get some sleep Bronson
plays you know what we wanted to do for
you Bronson uh John and I talked about
this already yes what we wanted to do
was shoot a reaction for you and just
send it to you so you have for your own
personal use oh you do whatever you want
you could upload it
so thank you Bronson I was like you know
what let's just give him a dedicated
video we are ready to do whatever you
want with it man we're gonna shoot that
today uh and yeah I mean we're just
gonna keep it uncut
raw it's not even gonna be your footage
in there that raw reaction just for you
um motossam
um I couldn't get fully immersed in the
film something big was missing and that
was the challah thoroughly enjoyed the
film though I find this an interesting
uh what time to do it I don't have time
to write down what the chat what episode
write down 28 minutes
I'll just figure I'll just figure out
what we're talking about that
um I couldn't get fully immersed in the
film I I've noticed that
now I'm not saying this is what you were
going through I'm not saying this is
what everyone was going through but I
have noticed they're having several many
conversations with people about the
movie is that
it's a funny thing when a grief I I and
I'm talking about friends that I know
that I've either not really dealt with
something devastating or a couple of
people I know that have dealt with
something devastating but they have said
like I just didn't have time to grieve
over it I didn't have time to deal with
it you know they kind of didn't want to
go through the process and it's not a
slight against them I think that you
know like I I did feel like the missing
presence of t'challa but I think that's
kind of the point I think his absence
was consciously felt yeah and I do
notice that there is sometimes and I'm
not saying this is the case it could
just be like you don't like the
filmmaking you don't like the
storytelling all right I can gladly
acknowledge that I I do know that
sometimes people have a hard time
allowing themselves to feel for
something this heavy and that's also
playing on something really real because
Chadwick Boseman did die and that's
obviously a part of the film
and if if you're someone who's I know
those are people who just can't really
connect with that if they haven't either
been through something or they don't
like to deal with those kind of emotions
you know and especially walking to an
MCU movie some really kind of thing you
deal with it you know I thought it was
really smart in the way they did certain
subconscious elements like this one had
a lot more vocalization versus the
talking drum like especially in total
Khan but even in in some of the wakandan
scenes they they had a verbal chorus and
I thought that added like a
disorientingly human element to the
score and that made you feel the
difference between the first films like
more James Bond flavor I feel like the
first movie even like the actually the
the chasing is a great example if you
look at the first film the chase scene
it feels very much like a James Bond
Chase it's got like those spy elements
and there's gadgets and like you know
they're in suits all of that uh feels
very James Bond and I've always thought
of black panther as very James Bond ish
this one they need to leave lean into
more of a geopolitical drama so I love
that the chase scene leading up to that
bridge in Boston is much more of a you
know down and dirty action that leads to
drama so they removed the Spy element
which feels like t'challa like he equals
that so I think they consciously were
looking at even the tone of the film of
how can we make sure that you notice
that t'challa is not here even when he
wouldn't be here like t'challa might not
be in that scene if we hadn't lost
Chadwick that might have been a scene of
those three women but they consciously
made it a different flavor so you do
notice and I think that was brilliant
and and good that we all wanted him we
all missed him and that was the point
I mean I can't really take a like I I
think you guys have just made very
eloquent and very solid points I think
there I can understand how somebody
might see this and and just because it's
it's life it's finite there's nothing we
can do I could see how you might just
not be able to click past the fact that
he is not there and it's like I get that
that's the point but sometimes you know
uh I think it's gonna I think sometimes
even if it's the point and even if you
acknowledge it's the point I could see
how you might still not be fully yeah
clicked into the movie because yeah I
mean that presence he did bring
especially for the amount of talk about
the first movie about you know oh like
t'challa is a very Regal character in a
lot of ways there are a lot of other
supporting characters who are much more
big and colorful but you know this movie
does kind of show you how he was the
core that guided all of the gravity of
that and without that core I think you
know I think we all think that they did
a tremendous job in using that and
embracing that but you know for some
people out there I can just see how it
it wouldn't be a scenario that you can
fully immerse into just because you're
so aware that he's gone and cannot be on
the screen and that's the thing is I
wouldn't have wanted any deep fake to
happen but at the same time I wonder
what might what people might say if they
did just to feel like he was their ish
at some point or even if they had done
some kind of like let's show him uh you
know
physically on his deathbed or something
like that which I think would have been
a bit ghoulish but I don't know I get
you can I I wrote an address a really
dumb comment
um this stupid ass uh so someone in the
chat just said stupid why would it be a
slight against anybody did not grieve
for a fictional character or even the
real uh man that you never knew crying
face laughy face slight goofy-ass
families no no I wanna I wanna
acknowledge it because I like these
people's ignorance there is a world we
live in where
fiction and non-fiction are your
experience the reason movies work at all
whatever shitty movies you enjoy or good
movies you enjoy it's because you and
your subconscious are immersed in the
story so someone's effect on you is
subjective because it's your experience
of knowing them so whether a character
is fictional or real whether they make a
movie about someone that actually
existed or someone that was a hero that
was written down doesn't matter because
your brain goes this affected me the
reason a horror movie can make you
scared is because it affects you in real
life the reason an action movie makes
you tense is because our brains are
wired to experience things so anyone
that experienced grief over losing a man
they had never met versus a character
they had never met or someone they had
met it doesn't matter because your brain
doesn't go real fake it goes I was
emotionally invested and your lack of
emotional investment or your lack of
emotional maturity or your lack of
ability to feel isn't our [ __ ]
problem so let people feel things and
let people grieve however they choose to
and if you don't feel that way keep it
to yourself because all you're doing is
yourself look stupid
you're just a Marvel fan
dreams I just people's people's lack of
emotional maturity about how people feel
about emotionality is so embarrassing in
this country and and I see a lot of this
about in this movie and it's actually
unacceptable
especially this movie it's it's it's not
an animated drawing it's a real life
person yeah and it would I think it
would have felt false for everyone
involved
um if they decided to just recast the
child I think it would have felt very
false sure I like that I don't think the
genuine part of the strength of this
film is the genuine emotion that you can
see on display and
if you I just how could you possibly
generate that it was like we got a new
actor we're just yeah I'm uncomfortable
by this even happening oh yeah yeah
anyway let's move on to more fun things
in life like this one sure he got me
emotional multiple times first movie
that made me cry in the first minutes of
the movie everything about that opening
in the MCU Fanfare had the tears flowing
or the lack of MCU Fanfare yeah that was
beautiful I do love the silence there
look Coy you won the crowd over I'm just
gonna remind people that he hated nemour
write it down
[Laughter]
yeah that's what we strive for and I
don't say I don't I wouldn't say then
don't make the movie I think what they
made with something beautiful and
powerful and different and unique and
something uh special for us for everyone
involved it's like I've heard several
people say that a lot all of us to
grieve I think it was really beautiful
especially juxtaposed with Thor which
you know the more we look on Thor wasn't
the same impact as this and I really
love that back to back we had that Rock
intro in the Marvel Fanfare which was
like jarringly different followed by
this very jarringly different and I
think my favorite thing about this is
the first thing I told Greg
silence is my favorite character in this
film I think that when you're going
through emotion the thing you avoid
first is silence I think when you're
going through lost the thing you avoid
first is silence and I love that this
film went from violent cacophony sight
sound stimuli to jarring silence so
often even the bridge fight which we
haven't talked about yet but is
incredible I love that you actually
heard the actual impact of things and
they used it and it felt like a dance
and it felt like a real tangible thing
and then the film bookends with Just
Wind and thought and silence the sound
of of shuri at the end of the movie is
the opening Marvel Fanfare that's the
same win that's the sound design of this
film is is you need to feel
uncomfortable
to grieve and there's little as
uncomfortable as silence going into
elevator with some strangers yeah it's
it's a very a powerful thing the absence
of something and what is more uh
translated than the absence of someone
than the absence of sound what is more
linear a feeling of we all universally
as a human race feel that tension when
you know something is missing and I love
that that was how they did the sound
design here I think this is the best
sound design in a Marvel film hardstop
oh yeah well and I feel like too they're
like there's something about uh when
when we lose people in a communal yeah
forget it uh when we lose people in a
communal sense I feel like uh you know
there's there's one thing to all be
tweeting about or something like that
but this is a situation where everyone
has come together to make this thing to
give to the pop to give to everybody and
then we all go it's like everyone goes
to church but except you know it's more
broad because it's the movie I like that
yeah it's a community grieving film yeah
uh Knight Captain do you think if
t'challa was still around would Neymar
be more aggressive and more like the
comics arrogant a-hole
I will never leave this town
every every live has one recurrent
question in it this is it I feel like uh
if t'challa was alive that if there was
a conflict that was one to one and there
was someone he felt might be his equal
it would be a Proving Ground if he is a
cuckoo con and is the god the serpent
God and people perceive t'challa as a
God I think the absence of a god figure
in wakanda is why he felt like he could
be less arrogant he could be all smooth
and Charming I do agree that was a part
of it and I'm not denying that was smart
personification again this is the
perfect cuckoo con for the film but I
would posit that if there was someone he
saw as his equal it would give him the
opportunity to show a boastfulness we
didn't get to see and I'm hoping that's
what we get to as we get more Neymar
well I think you know when at the very
endings I think he is a little bit more
compassionate and sympathetic as much as
commentary like this can upset people a
big part of it is
um you know his relationship with his
mom Amore's mom and then when you know
uh he's he's having a showdown with
shuri at the end and shuri is trying to
make an alliance a last-minute Alliance
when he's after she sees ramonda in the
astral plane he looks up at shuri and he
sees his mother so I think there is a
bit of a softer quality and even gives
shuri uh the mom's bracelet yeah so I I
think part of his softness can come from
the actual DNA characterization of
what's in the screenplay with no more
and his backstory where if it was
t'challa I think he would be kind of
like why the [ __ ] did you go open up and
talk about vibranium it's all about you
know then I think we would have gotten
that more aggressive version you know
and I do think it's it's been planted
like there are seeds of it so that gives
me hope like I do think we've seen the
potentiality right right right right
yeah for sure
TJ Langlois Lang Lois 1989. thank you
for the uh contribution I really enjoyed
the movie but I think they should have
found a better way to introduce Riri I
enjoyed her but every time she was on
screen it felt like someone had yanked
me out of the theater and on to Disney
plus
just like she all kicking down that
fourth wall
um you see the the thing that I thought
that they could have done to make
um the thing I thought they could have
done to make Riri feel a little bit more
to have that button of her feeling like
uh essential was the second time
watching because I've always liked Riri
in this movie I've always enjoyed her
and she is integral to the plot I I
don't agree with this assessment that
you could have done this movie without
her because I'm like she's such a big
Catalyst for everything the springboard
for it all and you know you said
something
um in your non-spoiler review and I did
notice it a couple of times here and it
was specifically when Ramona died when
Ramona dies and then I'm like I wish you
kind of just stayed
yeah and and then what I noticed was
like there's not really a scene with
Riri dealing with this and I think if
you cut out the Martin Freeman [ __ ]
someone just said he was
underappreciated I think if you cut that
[ __ ] out the re-re the Martin Freeman
Julie drivers If you eliminate that and
you instead gave a scene to Riri
Williams that was her feeling guilt and
feeling regretful because this whole
time she's being like no this isn't my
problem this is my responsibility why am
I here and then you gave her a scene
that was like Ramona died because of me
and if she was feeling the weight the
conflict of no no if she had had some
line in there like none of this she
hasn't seen with shuri of none of this
would have happened if it wasn't for me
yeah then that would have made her
character feel much more essential and
like she has some line at the very end
of the movie that's like yeah I thought
I should make up for you know for what I
did you know yeah
and then and it could have you could
have had something with sure jury being
like well then don't don't throw away
what you can do do something good with
it then and help me fight and then then
it would have made it more powerful and
meaningful and and I think if you had
given that her that screen time instead
of Martin Freeman and Julie Louis
Dreyfus then we would have had something
that would have added more
characterization and more necessity to
her character being in this film and it
would have thematically fit better with
everything they were doing do you think
that instead of I'm defending my boy do
you think instead of getting rid of the
Martin Freeman do you think just adding
would have been too long of the film
I know some people are facing issues
just keep his scene in the woods where
he talks to Okoye and shuri and then
yeah and then you lose the red or you
switch it up and have him create the
vibranium detector and make Henry
Williams they gotta protect the whole
potential that's right why isn't this
called wakanda Forever with Everett Ross
Everett Ross forever
colonizer first
uh I'm just gonna have to go through
this whole video and read you this seems
to listen to the whole thing back in
that colonizer forever
saw it too
we're all in that club now hell yeah
thanks for being here brother thanks for
being the super chat or or sister I'm
not sure uh David holler AKA Legion hey
guys love your Chanel I have been
wondering where you guys have a legion
in your Marvel TV ranking I never hear
you guys talk about it well I've never
seen it ain't seen that's why he doesn't
talk about it have you seen it uh I've
seen the first season
um I want to watch the red I actually
want to re-watch and all the way through
it's very high up there I think it
handles very existential thought very
well and it visually manifests a lot of
Concepts from the comics very well also
Aubry Plaza Delights right so it's
something that I really appreciate but
unfortunately when it was airing it was
in the time that things were just
starting to ramp up in comic book
culture and it's it felt like Fox was uh
not going to be carrying on so it was
like ah how do I juggle my time right I
do think it's worth watching and I
unfortunately haven't had time to watch
it
what I will say
I actually enjoy their scenes
I I didn't I enjoy because I enjoy their
characters and I enjoy their scenes I I
enjoy watching them
I I just think if there was something to
acts it could have been that if there
was something to trim the rundown it
would it could have been that and and
yeah you know what's funny Christian
harloff who uh what would have cut
ironheart and I'm like what yeah I don't
understand I'm like yeah yeah that
that's why I was saying what I just said
because I I think that would have just
it would have you could have kept every
scene the same if you just added this
one scene then it just would have
completely changed the context of all
those scenes yeah of if you added that
one thing with with reread because
there's not even an acknowledgment of
Riri being like she died saving me
because she did die saving it right like
if she had just gone up the water
herself instead of going back down to
grab her she would have been fine yeah
and then said she was like wakanda did a
lot for me then yeah
yeah you won
it felt like they were holding back in
the fight scenes I'm surprised there
wasn't any blood considering they fight
with Spears this is a Marvel PG yeah
that's more movie if we're gonna get the
violence and we're gonna get the moves
we're going to remove the blood but I
will see npaa not even nothing else but
but it's it's I still thought there were
a couple of moments where it there were
impact moments that it really hit I like
both times I've seen it when oh my God
I'm totally blanking on his name do you
remember the name of the guy who Okoye
fights one on one on the freeway
when when they fight
um there's a moment where he hits her or
where he he has the the the spear down
and he launches her into it both times
I've watched it the whole crowd a bunch
of both times super silent crowd but
that moment people Everyone goes oh like
they they're really who hits yeah that's
a real hit and when name when shuri uh
rips off uh one of his
um
when she claws his back too like you
yeah there's minimal blood but it's
enough to go like ow you know like yeah
I liked that the movie is is very
sorrowful and and poignant and silent
but the moments of of whoa are so big
because of it like the theater
experience is great for this one because
the silence again but then juxtaposed
with like very intense action yeah true
most awesome the nighttime underwater
see in IMAX I I didn't experience yeah
but but I've I've heard this complaint I
have yeah I have as well but I I didn't
experience it either time personally
theaters might be keeping their bulbs a
little low yeah
um cook save that money it happened it
happened yeah there's it's a it could be
a projection problem or maybe it is the
the fact that you do run into this issue
sometimes when you do film because they
shot it with an IMAX camera but then
when you convert it for a not iMac
screen because it loses a lot of that
resolution a lot of the data that it
gathered is compressed yeah so it just
might not be registered uh um dark but
but also I think you know because
oftentimes with CGI you know they might
dark it up so that way you can it looks
Blends better or looks more real uh but
on IMAX it looks phenomenal honestly
like it looks so realistic because it's
a blend of people really being
underwater and uh yeah so I'm sorry that
that was your experience with it so you
just like find 28 dollars
buy the most expensive screening that
you can and sit in some uncomfortable
seats for three hours to go experience
those water water
then leave the theater and make room for
Doom that is a fair point she does pull
herself off that spear in there is
absolutely nothing yeah there was no
blood on the spear that was in her but
it still feels painful [ __ ] when she's
like walking because there's no music
yeah yeah uh tins or tinsies yes it's
not bloody uh
thank you very much for chiming in how
do you guys feel about Namor killing
Queen ramonda in killing blood after in
in Kill blood after getting to really
know shuri and finding out what she was
lost and after finding out how close he
was with his own mother why do that
I well
I don't know yeah I think he didn't kill
her directly though
he intended on murder yeah I think he
did that to make her he literally
launches like like a hundred blocks
my mouth I was like all those bombs
and then he's like you're the queen now
I think to make her Queen so therefore
he could manipulate her I think he saw
that he could manipulate shuri easier
than raimonda so he killed God she is so
even everything
every breathing moment Angela Bassett is
on screen is just so like it's really
easy to call him like the oscar-winning
moment scenes you know like like the
scene with her nikoi my God which is a
powerful scene I don't know like I'm not
I'm not trying to slide it by saying
that but even like this really smaller
moment like when she is
was standing off with no more what I
love is the layers that she is
um
she is strong Stern but also scared you
know and you could feel all those
qualities like it doesn't matter that
I'm scared I'm gonna I'm not gonna show
that but you can tell she has that you
know and I think under current she
always has so much going on just under
what she's yeah and like that that as
much as like she doesn't she doesn't
have time to really grieve you know yeah
and she has to stay strong because she's
she's leading this like I love that
scene but she has when she's um uh
baiting and fish baiting no more on the
on the water and um you know like he's
like threatening he's like I'll tell
everyone about you he's threaded I'll
kill you and everyone like you can tell
she has to stand her ground but then
when she reunites with shuri you know
it's just like oh my God thank you I'm
with my daughter I thought I was gonna
lose my daughter and that's like the
feeling she was having that whole time
was I'm afraid of my daughter's gonna
die and I can't lose another child yeah
and and so I love that you got those
details of her performance just
throughout I I feel I genuinely believe
and you know what
I
I feel like she wouldn't get even into
consideration just because of the role
she plays in the movie but I feel like
Leticia Wright is [ __ ] phenomenal in
this film and I feel like she's just as
worthy of a candidate for Oscar
consideration but if there was like the
super obvious pick for me it would be
Angela Bassett well and what I loved the
second time around especially was it
really highlighted shuri's struggle with
faith yes which was there for me the
first time but the second time I was
like Wow throughout this is a huge theme
that is very subtly played for the most
and that's why I got rid of the vaccine
to me
I pulled it out giving back my immunity
she's so good I'm gonna listen to her
you know
they're they're cultural anyway uh
velune uh I thought that Iron
Man's friend how cool would that be if
Iron Man 3 kid went to MIT as well
little little uh Insidious boy
yeah I like that kid I like that
everyone was so confused when he's at
the funeral bring him back
they can use him at any time he is Canon
I like I like to think Tony like met up
with him at some point like off screen
they got Shawarma yeah and then they
were like what are you doing my kid you
creep I was a billionaire hanging out
with so many kids I I think that uh
what's his name from Miss Marvel likely
be in some point a guy in the chair or
some sort of superhero Builder uh maybe
with cherry and rigory all right Aisha
yeah you're right sure it would be
considered lead and raimondo would be
supporting female uh Devin World
building was top tier better than Black
Adam nothing is better than Black Adam I
think they did different things like
well they weren't trying to be the same
thing I interviewed The Rock Can't
criticize [ __ ]
once you hug that man it changes
everything people like Adam might have
been the best movie ever two days
I'm up seven pounds because of that hook
I'll call IFC call the film archive
we're gonna put black out you gotta
Scorsese down and you let him look at
him getting a Criterion you know what
that's what we need we need the rock
dogs Scorsese and then all this
discourse will stop and yeah
James Cameron hug Christopher Nolan all
those guys that only the rock can save
us
um
that's my official statement I don't
know why this comment's hidden oh let me
show this I saw this movie in 4k 40x and
yes I was very wet at the end
that's good
there would be tons
embrace your inner moisture
I am the guy that stays until the post
credits like the movie and like I always
say I appreciate you three's existence
thank you very much a lot thank you I
appreciate you thank you so many of
these
73 uh my friends were wondering where we
needed to be there
um how come the CIA didn't have our
machine reverse engineer ready to
replicate making her presence
unnecessary because they needed the
machine on hand
who would need to have the machine first
but they but it was a joint operation
they said between like seals and the
government and so that was the actual
retrievement that they never retrieved
it they never retrieved the machine
itself right no because okay it was
literally out of wakandan soil yeah but
how come they didn't before going taking
it into the water they didn't try
replicating it themselves you can't
replicate a Tony Stark suit she's
smarter than Tony Stark what are they
gonna do invent some Sciences
she can do it that is a fair point
though because yeah I guess they would
have had to have placed it down there so
they would have had it I guess you would
think some resourceful government agent
should have gone hey let's get the
controls
but at the same time depending on the
urgency you could tear it apart like a
card understand the mechanics it's not
like she's not it can't be that much
dark enough
iron man
it's off screen [ __ ] but it begs the
question like how urgently did they need
it because if you get this machine you
wouldn't just be like okay first thing
is we're going to dismantle it even
though we didn't build it so we don't
directly know how it works and we're
going to figure it out and then we're
going to use it she also mentioned the
software was so encrypted that she
forgot the password had a year of
getting back into that system so like it
could be argued that she was like no
this is uh firewalled true
and because plot no yeah it's mainly
just plot all right it's like the bottom
line is just plotting just roll with it
and it has a bit of a hole there if
you're on Orion George's pitch meeting
which I would love to see if he pulls
off a pitch reading for this film I'll
be the most eggshell walking pitch
meeting your ass has ever seen that
would be the kind of thing he would
point out Devin Punk record best
female-led comic book movie since Wonder
Woman 2017 fast is that the word on the
internet that it's like a woke movie oh
I'm sure it's got people who don't look
like the people complaining actually I'm
actually out of tune with it this time
around normally I love to make fun of
that
woke but I don't feel like it's like in
your face about it because they're all
from the previous movie
Williams are you upset that people that
use the word woke unironically have the
intelligence to look at the past
no that's something that didn't hit me
after the first movies I was like oh
yeah this is like a female female-led
experience because like the most
prominent male figure is what embaku
yeah who isn't who might be the next
like King but like you know and Martin
Freeman the most masculine presence
yes he's the night we'll do white wolf
he's the new white wolf get this man a
metal arm Tom Cruise and Last Samurai is
going to be that guy I love so much that
I watched this movie and felt nothing
too strong or against Martin Freeman and
now I'm like the Martin Freeman
cheerleader you know what guys
I like him uh uh and uh you know I enjoy
scenes don't wise thanks for the uh the
the I almost said economic but that
would be comic recommendations koi and
for the economic record I got you bought
my first one last week and now I'm
hooked your first comic ever wow last
week congratulations incredible dude
that's that makes me honestly that means
the world you are you just compensated
for 100 trolls reading comics because of
something I suggested that is the reason
I do all this thank you what if they're
reading the most racist reductive comic
do not go to Common skate's
recommendations
if you're reading good Comics I
appreciate you oh no he said one of my
recommendations I hope you enjoyed it do
you um do you think
um
the
Corey gave a whole speech Hannah earlier
about why they should the recast the
child movement and we'll we all agree
um but the soul Reaper in the chat did
say I want to get a quick 10 second
opinion here
do you think Bucky should have been at
the funeral
oh
the white wolf yeah yes agreed yes yeah
that was less than 10 seconds
ion blush
yo that killmonger Cameo would erase all
the defenses and get this man some golf
clubs
I want it I won that is my favorite
comment so far okay lightsaber thank you
hilarious common yeah I haven't pinned
my dude
from Forever at Ross whatever Ross lives
on
um
yes Eon blotch uh yo that killmonger
Cameo was boss agree like we talked
about earlier I thought that it was a
great use of narrative to propel the
character forward and also you know I I
would love if Just for future movies
sure he just keeps checking into the
astral plane to get some like Sterling K
Brown you know every character just
hardcore
hardcore motivation Everett Ross shows
up there at one point you're not even
dead I don't know I'm just out for a run
I'm in wakanda
I'm really and I've talked about this on
this channel quite a few times but I am
really curious about it and also thank
you Pieology I said uh you said you read
Comics because I mean now awesome thank
you
um I do Wonder with
the wakandan astral plane with uh you
know the the world of The Valkyrie as
well as the uh the field of reads as
well as all the things they looked at in
Moon Knight are we gonna have you know a
look at the Realms afterlives right like
are we gonna have something that
addresses that we all have these
different belief systems so like is that
something on the other side of a veil
much like a Miss Marvel I'm really
curious about if we ever get into that
stuff
uh totally listen to what you said it I
know you didn't know that I wasn't
Whispering
yes is someone's talking to me what's
going on yeah I can't hear you guys uh
let's see here I'm back now oh Berserker
yeah keanuary's Comics incredible uh
yeah
there's people gonna [ __ ] every every
stream has a bunch of people coming in
[ __ ] especially this movie people have
been mad since day one yeah since they
announced this movie I've seen a lot of
people take an issue with shuri's
ability to fight I'm almost at like
She-Hulk level exhausted it's only
weekend one but we'll see let's dance
internet I think I'm just so uh I mean I
know what I could have what I felt could
have been improved and I know what I
really loved I think I'm just I know my
opinion on this movie just so concrete
yeah I've been I've been looking at that
right like I don't think it's about my
opinion being wavered I think it's about
like I'm such a I believe that humans
are inherently good and I think every
time a movie comes out that makes me
doubt that it affects my experience of
humanity about the movie and I wish I
wish this was like fun but like in real
life I believe that people are
inherently wanting to make things better
for other people just as a foundation
and when something like a movie comes
out which is Art about sharing an
experience especially this movie that's
about staring at something as important
as sorrow and grief about addressing
something as important as emotionality
when people are
pig-headedly bigotedly racistly sexistly
stupid when they're when they're stupid
in such a specific way it makes me go
hey is Humanity worth fighting for and
and I know that there's gonna be
[ __ ] in the chat in a couple seconds
going like koi it's a movie koi it's
Marvel koi it's comic books whatever way
you want to demean and experience fine
but at the end of the day it's looking
at us as a culture us as a community
with that when something's important to
a number of people that it's enough
people that decide hey that thing's
that's important to you let me find
something to attack about it that's
specifically stupid to Rally you up and
then because the nature of the internet
that's the thing that rises to the top
controversy is the thing that goes to
the top simple-mindedness goes to the
top so every bit of intellectualism
every bit of nuanced conversation
inherently doesn't do well so you've got
Studios that pay for this stuff drowning
the things that are actually investable
and the things that rise up are the
things that are becoming Twitter now
look at Twitter now and I just I worry
every time there's a property that's in
any way important that the stupidity
wins every time time and I just don't
know if we can save people anymore I
just I don't know if it's possible
um I think you should go home uh no
reject that
no I don't I feel like I feel like it's
I don't think it's the majority though
it's not but they get to notice I think
they yeah they get the attention and
then also it is easy to you know do like
click bait on it like especially on on
like a YouTube platform you know
um or Twitter or whatever it's really
it's really easy but everything's
becoming clickbait because because the
rewards of the of the dopamine right you
get like 82 likes but it's dangerous of
course it is and I'm addicted I'm just
I'm just so afraid long term uh yeah no
I mean truth water comic joke
but you gotta what you gotta learn is
how to you know um go okay here's what's
going on with the world how do I
capitalize off this
but then I
passed the carcass of this conversation
let me vulture it's like trolls like
when there's a depression or an economic
crisis you buy stocks there's a way to
make a profit actually that's why like a
lot of people are like ignore trolls and
that's why I retweet them and comment at
them because I do Garner a bit of Joy
when they delete their Twitter so like
that that's me getting controversy
getting aggression out and eating their
corpse but I do worry that like that is
fueling and and it's only helping me not
society and I want to be like it's like
that song 3005 a childish Gambino right
like it's all about leaving something
that isn't for you to reap the fruits of
it's all about you have to I'm gonna
need you to recite all of the challenge
let me drop some lyrics okay so desert
[ __ ] two thousands is good good speech
but why do you hate names
laughs so Martin Freeman's problems is
my problem with trolls uh no we'll talk
off camera because the internet is is as
close to like a Bible as I follow and
it's really interesting because that
piece of all registers to me Bible man
uh the internet no no because of the
internet the album not the answer oh
because the internet
my mind when you said that went Childish
Gambino but then I was like Oh no you're
just talking about the internet no but
the idea of like it's like an
extenuation a continuation an extension
of the Matrix like the idea of this this
world we're entering in this digital
world but 3005 is about planting seeds
that we won't get to experience but we
know are helping society and that's just
one piece of that album and I like to
believe that what we're doing here is
enriching people's Movie experience
right we've got however many people
watching this not many people are going
to watch it later they already had their
Movie experience it's our job to enrich
it this we won't see the fruits of this
we'll never see how this affected other
people and that's why I love what we do
is we enhance other people's experience
after the fact we're giving people more
of the art they've already loved so that
is what I want to do for society what
worries me is that this will will not be
as popular as someone saying something
stupid and that that is terrifying yeah
I understand
are you sure you want to accept the G
fuel offers
you walk through my door I'm just aware
of how I feel Greg I'm working on my
emotionality but hear me out grown up
here Donald Glover I I agree no I you
know I agree with you go ahead I'm just
he's giving me some art and friends
that's my job here the release of the
tension is
doing the tension
but I'm not gonna deny what you're
saying yeah
sorry Chad a lot of comment love yeah
you're getting yeah I I feel like you
know we'll have people who come in here
who vehemently disagree and that's your
right to do it uh and I I love I think
with our audience it's it's the at least
the people who generally watch us is
it's funny you know it's like they tend
to sway more positive it could be
something that like is really not liked
like we obviously from our thumbnail
John and I did not really care for Black
Adam and of course the first top
comments
but I like that about the kind of crowd
we attract because they tend to be more
optimistic and tend to be more positive
and tend to be more loving and yeah I
love rejection like I wouldn't like like
I work with you guys because I love you
but it'd be hard to work here if I
didn't love them right yeah no you I
think I I generally like I really love
the people we attract because they tend
to be more positive
um I'm here on a Saturday and I love you
guys
so let's see people thanks for being
good people all right we gotta we gotta
get back on track here sorry guys Ronin
Unchained hi y'all expect more of these
from Koi today
imbaku cautious of Eternal war was great
I loved that scene I loved that point I
thought that was one of the most
eloquent points in the movie in fact I
think what they did within Baku is neat
because there was that when he is
talking with her in that scene and the
way they position the the framing when
he's like looking like it specifically
starts at the scene at Ramona's funeral
and but then in that scene when she is
Black Panther and he's and she's like I
want to kill the more and he's like I
don't think you should do this it's not
what your mom wants where he's being
positioned to be like a surrogate older
brother for her now and I think that was
kind of beautiful how it works also the
continuation of the Ark from the first
film where in the first film he's just
seeking power right and in this film he
has the ability to wield power and he
does it maturely and then at the end
it's him being he's earned the spot to
challenge for that power like I love the
Arc of embaku especially and how I would
have loved more of him but I think
whenever he's on screen he does so much
yeah he's brilliant I think I think he's
so funny
you both had the demon
people pointed that out
it also took me forever to realize it's
just a small detail but that they're
talking about her makeup and the first
time I was like where did her tattoo go
and then I realized oh that's not makeup
that's a tattoo she had to cover yeah
the tattoo
but yeah that's a good point I'd put
that together so it's just now yeah yeah
have concealed tattoo
TJ Lang Lois 1989 on Kevin Conroy
shifting gears I only ever saw him once
at my only con and it came as I rounded
the corner on writer's row and he was
standing on his table and screamed I am
Batman and it was extremely surreal that
sounds surreal that's a life moment man
goodness I'm glad you got to experience
that that's cute I'm a Vengeance I am
the Knight
I am Batman that's such a brilliant oh
God I'm gonna watch one of those today
he's an upset or a movie is there
anything streamlabs by the way
let's go see we haven't checked at all
I'll check someone went on a rant I
could check here ruined the flow uh yeah
koi rant never
I'm known for my brevity John you know
logging
all right while you're doing that uh I'm
gonna read JC's comment I may be
entirely wrong
uh but did they actually show to Saint
earlier in the film when Ramona went to
visit Nokia in Haiti hey yeah uh when
she first shows up right yeah he's the
kid that greets ramonda yeah okay so we
do have a couple in our in our stream
thank you to all who contribute to our
super chats and streamlabs by the way
and uh I know this is coming from your
own hard-earned dollars that really does
mean a lot to show your support all
right we don't really go live that often
so thank you really means a lot and uh
playbacks on these are always weird so
thank you guys it's extra long yeah so
thank you
um let's go uh where are we at John
all right we are in uh do we we talked
again about this yeah let's let's go to
the let's go through the lists here we
don't end a stream until we go through
them Fred jorgens wasn't anticipating
falling in love with the Namor portrayal
koi yeah koi I'm happy for Fred boy I'm
happy for Fred [ __ ]
name more with more way more
do you follow that guy on Tick Tock that
does the Eminem Impressions
I love that dude hilarious yeah he's got
it down power it's like in a
relationships
don't make the grocery list Rhymes he's
falling down the stairs and there's some
close-ups on the hand when he's like
okay and some cheddar cheese please
Olivia introduced me to him it was so
freaking funny oh God that [ __ ] was
hilarious Oscar Franco thank you for the
Super Chat my friend I saw the movie
last night and I love the fact that when
the Marvel Studio intro was forming it
didn't have the traditional music behind
it and it was paying tribute to Chadwick
Boseman and gave us a moment of silence
yeah Corey really touched on that um
earlier in the Stream about The Silence
it was weird in our screening yesterday
someone shouted at the screen fix the
sound to the projectionist I'm just
joking
literally I was about to retroactively
no except for 100 people in the theater
I'm like
Mankind's broken that's what did it
I'd go live in a cave not a negative
comment about the movie they thought of
him see messed up
just hurt my spirit
did we talk about the uh tie in with
Haiti
um uh him being named after the French
yeah yeah I mean I know we talked about
that in our um in our actual yeah if
people didn't know I just thought like I
mean John's the one that I heard Saint
by the way two Saints apologies I think
that's incredible credit scene on my
computer to make sure I was getting I
mean
that's the American pronunciation it
doesn't
Tucson Tucson is such a great idea
because the like leading up a revolution
and all those things I think it's just
really clever that his secret identity
so to speak is also such a badass name I
love that yeah yeah it has a great
legacy
um Eddie Terrell
Neymar's arrogance was warranted because
he was it just keeps going his arrogance
because he was literally leading his
people and killing Spanish settlers as a
child yes
yes didn't feel like arrogance felt like
justification which I agreed with
because it seemed fair I feel like
killmonger was more of a name or the
name or what does arrogance mean
let's get the having or revealing an
exaggerated sense of One's Own never
exaggerated abilities
yes it is not yeah it is always well
Justified I guess is I guess
I was right I guess Namor does not
kind of I mean like you know no one
knows about him and he's acting like
everyone's gonna like destroy him he was
the exact right character for the film
well he's in the position they're in in
the first movie you know he's it's like
yeah telecon's another wakanda it's a
parallel and I do love that the wakanda
films both of them now deal with a war
under the surface literally in this case
but in the first film like the looming
sense of War I think that's great to
keep it feeling different than the rest
of the MCU there are different Stakes
which I love I think if Neymar was smart
he would open up a water park I think
he's got the power side he's the
greatest water park on Earth vibranium
water park aircraft
[Music]
that is the application of that
technology
that's what Americans would do is like
we don't want to attack you we want to
monetize can we build Seven Flags but
here's the thing at Disneyland if you
took the submarine ride and made that
talocon that would be so cool
name more cool X-Men Supreme thank you
for the Super Chat Neymar was not
arrogant he's responsible for his people
he's seen the greed that drives a
certain see he's saying he's not
arrogant but really like but it's not a
criticism he's agreeing with me he's
agreeing that he's not arrogant which is
my flaw but does he need to be arrogant
because well yeah because he's
effectively in the right which I also
like wakanda like if you look at the
first film t'challa ends up doing what
killmonger suggested in his own way have
some more conflicting in the movie it's
the right choice for the movie Coy says
at the top of this
I've seen the great that drives the
service Society he's a hundred percent
correct in his actions yeah so it makes
him a good villain in the movie when
humans drove them there they got the
small packs from the colonizers right
yeah yeah which I love that uh rebooted
origin I released Choice yeah smart
colonizers man they're getting a lot of
crap this year you know Conquest is a
tricky business
oh golly let's let's uh let's let's go
back watching praying I'm just like
what's going on what's wrong with these
French guys Jesus give me some context
um to Saint also means All Saints Day
meant to celebrate lost loved ones I
didn't know that
that's a beautiful
beautiful Tale
in my opinion Aquaman is still better
than the more though that's subject to
change but telecon is so much cooler
than Atlantis
fascinating I think that it's
interesting you bring up Aquaman
specifically because that's another
characterization where it works in the
movie but it's not the character in the
comics like Jason Momoa got to be Jason
Momoa uh in those movies like he's like
yeah he's playing like a really cool guy
like Aquaman is a guy that's like a
little more stiff and stoic and golden
agey and talks to fish Jason Momoa was
like all right Dolphins yeah and that's
fun oh man my man
I'm hoping he's low but we'll see he
does do a great job there
um Chad dirkiewicz what's up with him
Baku challenging the Throne of the end
sorry if I misspelled his name well I
think my a big question I have is
earlier in the movie
um and I didn't catch it the first time
or didn't really stick with me the first
time but it it it re-contextualized the
end scene for me where
um Nokia
offers
shuri she says like you can stay with me
in Haiti yeah so is she going to is she
moving too I think she relinquished the
throne yeah okay so she's just gonna be
the Black Panther so to answer the
question like yeah she'd be the Black
Panther
um I think we're separating the two
titles because the Black Panther needs
to be there usually not to fight in
wakanda specifically I mean in this
movie yeah uh but uh usually it's to go
out and do something right
um so yeah I think I think she would
yeah be the Black Panther but there was
still so much of that purple stuff left
I'm thinking more art shape herbs I
think they get more black yeah they're
just planning them but like but it's
still a an honorary title I think
there's gonna be multiple I think you
can only have one at a time you should
make multiple that's it team I think I
think having one president of the United
States is terrible idea but I think
separating the committee I think
separating the the fighting title from
the honorary title from the presidential
title smart no I I it is I think it
makes sense what embaku's doing I don't
think he's challenging her her
yeah he says like she won't be joining
us but he wants to be you know the the
King still but he's not asking to be
black panther that sounds like his bless
like she has blessed him with that that
seems like she dropped him off to do
that yeah I also love that that little
ending beat where it's like I've got
somewhere else to be and then they show
the three places she could show up and
then in the morning I thought that was
so clever like we are assuming she's
gonna go to that spot they cut to it
we're assuming she's gonna save her off
they cut to it and then it's she's
taking the time she should have taken to
mourn her brother which I loved I'm
gonna make a quick list of things we
gotta talk about at some point uh
midnight Angels koi suit
okay
um let's go here raccoon shampoo
they had to keep restarting the first 10
minutes of the film since they kept
cutting sound wow holy [ __ ] what a
nightmare of an experience you imagine
just sitting there in a wheelchair with
your eyes taped open for that it's just
like keep watching the first 10 minutes
of black panther forever
and then the pitcher and then didn't cut
the light so unfortunately a lot of the
power that opening is lost in Earth
either Jesus that's awful I am so sorry
there's a funny story to be had there
though if it makes you feel any better
there was a mild electrical this is not
nearly the same impact of film but there
was a mild electrical fire at the
premiere of Hobson Shaw so we were like
a little ways into the premiere of a
movie the world premiere that we all had
to evacuate the theater so like that
movie's Pace was like action action
actually Jason's safe in The Rock and
they were all like ah I gotta leave and
it was one of the more memorable
experiences what was the movie that we
saw it was wanted he no no no no no no
the the the uh the son of famous
director oh Fury of the fists and the
Golden Fleece or whatever so
um this was the decision in the real
rejects time of I'm never agreeing to do
a paid review
that was the movie like there have been
times where people offer like like
sometimes they offer you like crazy like
amount of money sometimes they're like
we'll pay three thousand dollars to
watch this and just do a review wow and
I always turn it down and like because
I'm like no because like it it you put
me in a very awkward situation yeah how
do you be honest yeah where I can't be
honest and I gotta go around my words
without being like diving into the
cruise I hated it but anyway my
experience it was uh it was it was a
terror I waited some time before I
finally came out I was like no it's an
awful movie but I couldn't say that
right away
um we had to do that whole review being
like if you like this kind of thing more
specifically specifically
when we went
um they they had a whole bunch of people
there and um and and it was and Logan
Paul wasn't even there and uh didn't
talk to him this was like a little bit
after the Japanese uh Japan
yeah there's a little bit after that and
he was there and and and
um he left because we were there for two
hours and the movie wouldn't like it was
like eight or nine and it started after
11. yeah
he's like nah I'm out yeah yeah
Michael J white stuck around though
hell yeah he was right behind Cynthia
Rothrock through that and that was cool
uh exhaling one the pauses
a loud reflection I'm a therapist
I'm a duck it was like a session we use
signs to allow space so were you there
during the movie Star Trek bones kind of
thing yeah
exhaling one Kirk I'm a therapist being
a therapist seems like a thankless job
we appreciate you very much but also
that's that's good to know damn it
rejects I'm a therapist
you listen I don't like the sound of
this
I like that the name is excaling one too
like I'm a therapist this is the way it
is right it's so funny but I suppose if
I had more pauses there I wouldn't have
read it that way uh yeah I agree no you
should have paused between each sentence
to allow Reflections That's The Power of
meditation and just focusing on
breathing I think you know uh sometimes
there's all kinds of ways to meditate
and I think sometimes the most basic way
is just close your eyes and breathe for
10
set a timer and just do deep breaths for
10 minutes it really helps
um trashy NG
um and also I I go I think we all go to
therapy now right yeah
with my eyes wide open and I hold my
breath
I just sit there for an hour and I just
wait for it to end no I couldn't do this
job without therapy there if he's the
reason I'm alive
I just go through all my thoughts in my
head and then I just leave I just rattle
around stressed out for an hour I just
pay someone not to yell at me for
sitting in silence for this long here
trashy Angie this movie fixed a lot of
personal problems uh I had I should have
read the whole thing a lot of my own
personal problems my marriage was healed
sorry I reconnected with my child I lost
my child my wife left me
oh my God what's that from oh the key I
wanted to do it feels good yeah chain
wax yeah this move fixed a lot of
personal problems I had with the
previous phase four movies where I
wasn't as emotionally invested the use
of science throughout really helped with
that oh interesting how that really
helped with that it's kind of like
Breaking Bad
um that's what this movie is
when Tyler concerts
sorry we have to cook yeah [ __ ]
vibranium we don't need any more pseudo
I have this glowing herb from telucard
what is I wonder I am curious uh what is
what does that comment mean the use of
science throughout really help with that
uh is it is it like a connection you
have with science just in general and or
or or or is that or is this auto
corrected from Silence yeah
[Laughter]
there's so much science
I love both options very much well you
know and I guess you could say that
there is you know that scientific
struggle you watch her really putting
her head onto the you know figuring out
how to make the herb are you still in
the chat you need to clarify for us yes
um all right we'll know in a few minutes
hopefully all righty here uh Aguilar hey
koi uh I was able to avoid spoilers yeah
I cried a lot at the end loved all the
action the music no more
I can't name or uh but the movies really
goes out of its way to call them the
more so now I feel like well not love
right I love that like I think it was a
really clever way to rename him Ramona
doesn't say name or at one point so
you're good oh that was a flub the queen
said it Falcon Millennium Falcon
Millennium Falcon trashy angels
okay she didn't
yeah I I could have seen the science
version if you're a scientist you
connect emotionally to it that shows my
sincerity sounds like sarcasm um
well sorry
I'm gonna go all literally again and
[ __ ] everybody
Sherry's Journey earner the mantle it's
in my top five hell yeah I I think it
isn't my top five for me personally too
I know the whole MCU yeah wow
all right judgmental money I just didn't
know it's in my top 22. I would say top
ten I think top 12 for me top ten uh
does that mean it's number 12. Jesus
Christ
when you go with a specific number I'm
like it has to be 12 or 11 because it
would have been what a weird thing to
say yeah like then you just say it's
number 12. we are gonna do a ranking of
my phase four so I saw someone ask
earlier that is that is on the agenda
yeah but we're in for Guardians Holiday
Special A lot of people brought I put
out a community post oh did you asking
like should we do a ranking of the
movies or movies and shows and like a
lot of people are saying wait till
Guardians oh yeah oh yeah I forgot
that's part of space foreign
of not a phase four of the whole thing
way to ruin the reveal a reveal what
yeah
it's at the bottom there's a gap that's
my 12 overall McQ what you're saying
um yeah it's it's uh I I love this this
is just the kind of movie I it's just my
my jam
like is that you do some like think
about grief and I'm more likely to be
into it prior rain this movie won me
over on not recasting t'challa and
Leticia ride taking on the mantle she
did an amazing job in the film I just
love hearing a respectful comment once
in a while I agree uh the chat has has
been debating
uh the the hypocrisy or not of not
recasting t'challa but recasting William
Hurt oh my God it's not the same [ __ ]
thing at all not even close like William
hurts the Mount of
presence
necessity role impact on culture impact
on a people in fact on the movie yeah I
I don't know anyone who's seen
a single like man what if the takeaway
is like the the weight of General
Thunderbolt Ross in that film yeah like
I I don't feel like it's not it's not
saying he did bad I'm not saying that
I'm just saying it is a completely
different emotional Association
contextual Association when it comes to
Thunderbolt Ross's presence in the films
than it is with lead actor first like
African superhero like there's so much
more going on with who black panther is
what that represents who that means the
role of Chadwick Bose like so much more
than than a general Thunderbolt run and
there are other examples of like Don
Cheadle was you know behind the scenes
money stuff and then like even Ed Norton
was the type of character he's playing
in a team versus singular like it wasn't
the loss of a man this movie was about
mourning the character and the man it's
not the same as like it didn't work for
us in this creative Direction it wasn't
a creative decision it was a we need to
all collectively and it enhanced the MCU
because now there are
more emotional resonance in these
characters because of this film so I I
don't think you can compare Ross or
cheetah or Norton to this this is a
completely different thing one and
William Hurt had a full and I would
argue maybe more com you know he was his
career wasn't cut short you know and he
also in his life she he was around
longer yeah in life you know whereas
like Chad who I was getting ready to
film this one yeah and then uh yeah hurt
had a long full life yeah it was yeah
also everyone go dive bombed the jabby
Coe stream
um yeah uh don't I was if you watch
jabby koi stream just know it's it's not
as good
did he like it he was he was next to us
in his reactions to the movie just
weren't as good he was at like a seven
the whole time stayed like that if you
want to have a seven out of ten he
wanted more effort right he actually has
uh he says different opinions and he
actually has some really uh his live
streams are actually really fun they are
I enjoy that I have a lot of listen back
to a lot of them
sure I can see I could see how people
might like the bookends of this movie
you know I could see people being like
yeah I definitely still cried at the
beginning in the end and maybe a scene
or two but overall there's because the
movie is is slower and it's more it does
play more like a drama instead of
because it takes a while before the the
pulse of the film really because because
after Riri gets taken by insuri after
the freeway fight the movie really does
like slow down a lot yeah it slows down
significantly
and and it just becomes kind of
meditative or some [ __ ] you know like it
really slows down and then the pulse
picks back up once uh name or attacks
McConnell and that's a while before that
happens you experience like grief and
like those pauses and stuff and that's
not gonna be for everybody like we
talked about yeah and also Thunderbolt
Ross I would say too is yeah like I mean
someone says thunderbol Ross kind of a
dick the thing too is like yeah there's
a heroic association with with uh it's
just such a difference also we've also
had multiple Ross's already like Sam
Shepard was Ross in the old Banner one
like it's not like a character that's as
Associated Sam Elliott thank you yeah
wow I'm off the Schmo down I'm out we
all are uh wondering Seth can we discuss
how Neymar look like he'd never swim
before
Neymar is a rift swimmer where it looks
like he skipped the gym Kamal Kamil
nadiani did it
can you imagine kamehame in this role I
like to swim under the water he do his
voice eyes I like to swim under the
water
I mean this is uh
I I do uh it's weird he he did have some
shots
like like in the right lighting where he
did look like really cut obliques and
and makeup to a hell of a thing
um yeah Corey clearly has an issue I
just think that uh should have got more
cut I'm just there's a certain
I think uh it it is an attainable body
heat
sure
right back the
distracted by it because I'm like he's
gonna have super strength whether or not
he's cut he's gonna have unusually
enhanced super easy and maybe it's very
cold and he needs a little insulation
but but it is it is like he does swim a
lot though you would think he'd have a
bit of a swimmer's body I feel like
there's nothing I can say as someone who
values Fitness that doesn't sound like
body shaming they should have cast
Michael Phelps I think he just did it
right now but I I just acknowledge the
fact that I'm in the corner and I feel
like then we just move on
sexy my man's was looking sexy I like it
like I said if Sue left read for that it
would make sense I will acknowledge the
fact that he seemed very Charming I
found it interesting that they credited
him as introducing uh but anyhow has he
not done he's on didn't he come from
wasn't he on narcos or something this
was his first role he's ever done
[Laughter]
you're losing the crowd koi take that
shirt off do the do the PEC dance you
need to go on a rant again about Society
yeah how they suck I think tell off the
anti-woope mobbed
everything Malik Curry loved everything
about this movie maybe loved Namor the
most I just found myself just found
myself longing for that t'challa versus
Neymar fight I think it would have been
so awesome what do y'all think true
Chadwick I mean really quick I put on a
tune millise comment no Jim's
intelliconi and the natural fit bod you
get when you just do yard work there was
a truth
I love the idea of to locate yard work I
just need to start there
as the guy doing ab workouts or anything
like he's just like yeah I move [ __ ]
around you know I'm a guy he's got like
that 70s Action Hero bot yeah that's
true well it just needs a lot of water
you just needs some hair on his body and
that would be the one this is the
aerodynamics yeah no no truly true yeah
sure it's different I don't know
um oh I hope this guy doesn't get like
fat shamed yeah that's right that's a
good point Aisha that it's cold or
underwater and that's why I didn't say
nothing
no he looked strong and that's what
matters like truly yeah Zac Efron has
that weird weird haircut to take over
the role
it's been cool to see t'challa and no
more fight but you know
I think it would have been that would
have been an epicasso there's no denying
that like look in an alternate universe
as Chadwick was around uh yeah I would
preferred the movie with Chadwick
Boseman of course
um but in the in the universe that
exists where he does not he's not around
uh this is I I would prefer this over
the recast the child movement and then
someone's coming in the Stream now and
be like what
um they're coming they're waiting uh so
here we go since when this channel
became no we're not that's the whole
point of what we're saying we just said
we don't want to do it and blush is koi
gonna rank all MCU Heroes phase one
through four oh Heroes like the villains
video we could
I just need a longer day because that
day was stressful I lived here
you know you had to take a meeting I
literally like ran into the other room
to like take a meeting midday
um yeah well probably that's a good
title idea I wanted koi to do uh action
scenes yeah I think we definitely should
do that should we include Netflix there
though best ever at Ross moment because
the hallway's gonna I was thinking I
think we did like all likes
uh I think we Marvel such as MCU because
um yeah I'm like they're they're some
cool like Berserker stuff I think Blade
fight is better than the opening of
blade is one of the best things period
one day
one day John doing his channel and then
uh get together I keep forgetting that
it keeps affecting me big Community
guideliner up I'm conflicted by the
whole recast him argument Mischief
manager says would people have accepted
a recast of RDJ as Iron Man and MCU
timeline great point I just think it's
yeah I know I think it's so um
to yeah I I I think it would have been a
distraction you know like I I it's on a
smaller level I I watched this show
Spartacus and the first season was this
phenomenal lead actor uh playing
Spartacus and then the actor who played
him passed away in between uh before
Season Two started so they had to recast
him
and
I couldn't see past it so like I just
couldn't see fasted I was so aware
of the one I was married to you know
prior and and while people really liked
that season of season two I had the
hardest time seeing Pat and I think on
this level
think about it too it's like yeah people
opt for recast inshallah but then then
the people opted for recast in Charlotte
you'd just be arguing with the people
who were saying they shouldn't have done
it and you wouldn't have this feeling of
of we all got to celebrate them instead
of instead of watching a movie where
there was another job we got to
celebrate Chadwick and t'challa we had
to celebrate the man in this case
exactly exactly yeah we got on we got to
really honor a real life person here
raccoon shampoo was that final fight on
the barge a little small scale and weird
to you guys it was a weird fight I don't
think it really hits that fight on the
scale I kind of would have liked if they
just had that fight and then they just
sort of dealt with the fight on the
beach because Divine on the beach I
thought was more yeah it was it was like
just kind of noisy to me that fight on
the barge we'll make the top Marvel
fights list tell you what no that was
kind of noisy and I'll take this time to
bring up a koi suit I'm not a big fan of
the Midnight Angel suit personally
um I think it does look kind of like it
looks a little goofy and I'm and I'm
just not a fan of
putting her in something that removes
seeing her face I'm not that I don't
like also if we're living in the world
where like my adaptation versus
translation argument with with an amor I
think he is the best thing suited for
this we then shouldn't have to be
married to a comic design in a movie so
like if something looks cool in 2D
drawing that isn't always going to
translate to 3D so you don't always have
to make it screen accurate if it's gonna
look off and I feel like they were
trying too hard to make it look like a
thing that it can't it does kind of look
like the the uh an outfit you would see
in like the Predator movies yeah yeah it
didn't quite work for me but like a like
a some weird like action figure version
of The Predator with like alternate
colors yeah yeah but there is something
about that too where and I don't I won't
labor this point too hard but having
more iron folk essentially flying around
almost kind of lessened the impact of
having a Quay in the fight to me and and
uh Nika who gets the other suit I think
uh just you know it's like okay great
more power suits too right really yeah
that is an issue to really sweep [ __ ]
off the side of the barge and all that
stuff you know uh let's see here Matthew
white The Happening part two you know
the scenes why you eyeing my lemon drink
right what who what do you mean you
recast each other
we need more scenes whatever Ross okay I
really think it shows the geopolitical
conflict all right look sorry we gotta
go attack the surface World okay
before I kill her all right let's just
start a review Channel
can we do an entire Mark while brick
livestream we should rank the Marky Mark
movies as Marky Mark I do enjoy watching
Mark I really like the Fear movie I
think it's underrated figured Reese
Witherspoon that one red wow
it's true
he's doubling Bill Bill Finger I always
know about probably thinking artist Bill
Finger yes noted fantastic Batman
Creator there you go what time is it in
the Stream
I can save this
fluffy men can be heroes too exhaling
one and uh koi's comment corner is
getting love in the chat someone wants
you to do Stan Lee Camp it's overrated
[Music]
I also love that it built character
development while being a fight because
I was loving comic book movies when they
like Advance the plot Advance the
character and have a cool fight so like
the whales and the power set the
intimidation all that stuff like
building off of ironheart's origin was
genius and I think um I think also
you know I if we got to point out
deniagara scene where she is fired is uh
oh that's coming up I remember watching
it and oh it's coming up yep then
everyone shut up two questions away x
man one man wolf pack x one of my real
gripes was that none of the Avengers
Charles funeral they were busy
they were in the sequence they should
have got an earlier notice uh it was
very weird of me considering so many
showed up to Tony's but they were so
quick to claim to cholo as their black
friend
maybe maybe it was more of a and this
kind of answer is the white wolf
question like maybe they just really
were fortifying wakanda and they also
maybe there's a a a tradition thing
where like in Tradition it's it's the
wakandans mourn their King and I think I
think they also for emotional context I
think you would have been more focused
on the fact the vendors were there you'd
be very distracted instead of on the
funeral legendary but like so I'm
thinking plot wise I I like that it plus
plot wise I could say like tradition
equals but then it would have been
distracting if they tried to make those
cameos well I think I mean I'm sure the
Avengers could find a way to do it in a
non-descript way but I think having
everyone there only gives more
opportunity for the rest of the world to
really it's like they make a lot of like
behind closed doors you guys know what's
going on in wakanda and are plotting
based off that but if you had the
Avengers show up it might be like a
global event that they probably don't
want sure
Lapine Jordan Walker if you close one
eye you can only see John and Greg
they're next to each other and I'm not
here funny it was mainly just me and a
bunch of women
and then it was just John had the thing
to deal with at 1.2 when and I was like
John would put you on camera now all the
time and people were like where's all
the other guests
where's all the women don't worry I'll
be replaced by a bunch of women so I'm
just offering Solutions every time you
start bringing on someone they're always
like I'm this dude I missed the time and
I'm like you'll adjust before you'll
leave you'll be replaced with someone
else
same with Queen Ramana nikoye conflict
hit hard that was I didn't see that
firing and I noticed in the
when she is talking with the council
everyone at the council can see what's
about to come
and I didn't notice that until the
second time watching it that everyone
could see that was about to happen
um and a koyage just like she knows her
her job in determining and it's like
they just can't register like guys I was
in the most impossible situation like
they're Immortal I can't I couldn't
defeat them
um but yeah her her um when she's broken
down because when she's the first time
she was fired the first time I saw it I
was like I just I think I said out loud
I was like what I was so heartburn like
damn sure was so mean
yeah but I also unders I really
understood it in the SEC because I was
feeling so emotional towards her firing
there and then of course Angela bass's
beautiful speech there but I denied
her's performance there where she's like
becoming desperate and pleading is so uh
is so it was gut-wrenching and seeing
you know if they cut out like more
Martin Freeman stuff they couldn't give
him mccoying more screen time to flush
but what if it was her yelling at Martin
Freeman no
no I love that I lost my job
I loved I mean
I love that also that her reaction was
like honor right like right the the
reaction was dignified the spear felt
like a a beautiful resignation and then
like you know what that meant to her so
I love I love that both feelings like
you really felt for both sides of that
equation and the awkwardness of being in
that room that everyone was like I see
what she's saying but oh yeah like it
was a really beautiful scene maybe my
favorite scene in the whole movie to be
honest Cena Bigelow says that seed made
me feel like I was being yelled at damn
and I I absolutely agree
um you're just there to koi issues at
that moment clouded memory
um thank you gotta say as much as I love
the end credits scene uh sure you being
the only family member who didn't know
Fields really messed up I understand the
meta reason for why she wasn't told if
she knew that changes her character Arc
it's an interesting point actually you
know I've actually never considered that
way why was she the one left out of
knowing that I I feel like to Chala
especially with his relationship with
cherry would have told her I would have
wanted her to know if the queen knows
why not his sister yeah
that thing where she said where she can
keep a secret not true what's the first
thing an untrustworthy person says you
can trust me yeah Anderson my brother
has a son
that is that is a great
I don't know why I never thought about
that at all I was so emo I was invested
so emotionally I didn't think of the
plot problem with it yeah yeah
um
weird maybe they just really wanted to
keep it contained uh I don't know sure
he's scared of children see if I hosted
q and A's these are the kind of things I
would ask just to see if like oh but I
try to ask like a bit of a bold question
like I'm kind of curious about this yeah
because the actors like they are so
invested these characters they'll have a
reason yeah like like Leticia Wright
would have thought of a way and odds are
like they just couldn't cover it and
then yeah
usually they they will know they will
know a plot they're usually they're not
like I don't know I never thought about
that yeah and it's because Ryan coogler
said and Ismail uat points out that like
you guys said she tries to tell her by
the fire but I don't think that even
solves it because it's like why wouldn't
she have just known when the child was
conceived before Caleb says she was
trying to remember sure wouldn't take
her call she did keep calling remember
oh yeah at the very beginning
another thing is but the problem but the
problem is this keeps going for me
because then I I think like well yeah
she's been calling and and t'challa is
ill but you would imagine that this
child is old enough by the end of the
film that he's more than two years old
so the the kid would have had to have
existed for a minute before he got sick
it would seem like
so but she wasn't there since he got
dusted because she said she's been gone
for six years yeah oh Fair all right
maybe that does solve it
she got to take those phone calls from
you when from your sister-in-law it's
important talk to family especially when
it's not yet always yeah yeah no we know
what Ramona said that by the fire and
she was gonna tell her there's a
five-year span that I can't rationalize
why she didn't know
um no that's a good point that's a good
point no I know people are people are
saying that no we acknowledge it yeah
Ramona was going to tell us when your
child is six yeah um but that was still
yeah that was that was like a few days
before she met the child uh of what
we're saying is like how come in all the
all these years she never was informed
about like years one through five or
zero through five I'm wondering yeah
like why was you know that's my that's
what we're trying to say
um
but who knows we uh lucky BX hi guys
Reports say fight he said uh no more
film is contingent on the success so
we'll Conor forever if Greenland do you
think Google should direct I I think
there was probably a question of is
there going to be any more film and then
he probably says something like see how
this one does no I don't think it's like
I'm gonna see if there's a dollar Mark
before like I'm just acknowledging the
phraseology here I feel like poor Kevin
foggy says like the sky's blue people
are like I don't know if the grass is
green enough oh yeah no no so like I
think it's gonna depend on where this
10-year plan is more than like what
dollar amount this hits that said it's
doing quite well I wouldn't mind in a
more movie
yeah we're just super arrogant maybe
they could do the movie before this
where it explains
shuri was blip too so she was gone for
five years kids six years old in that
year doesn't answer the call problem
solved first so for a whole year she
wasn't answering the call yeah she was
mourning him for she was warning him and
we saw her and she was probably upset
that Nakia wasn't at the funeral exactly
so she had a reason not to answer she's
going through a grief that's why yes
okay we did it we did it thank you to
everyone thank you to everyone for
helping us come on so what's a possible
question though yeah like think about it
I feel dumb because of exclamation
points but I appreciate it I know you
gotta do that's a thinker thank you guys
I appreciate that does it does answer
yeah
you know we know the queen tried telling
story that's not the question I was
wondering that too Kenneth Anderson if
Neymar's Wing can grow back or not or is
he just gonna be flying funky no it's a
sense that it's his G-spot
so if you can say that word
he's got a bit of a bit of a moment just
there and then come on come on it was
funny it was very funny it was funny it
was a funny line
I came Jeremy shields uh I think he can
regrow it because uh the what we saw
with everyone on the on the battlefield
being able to regret stuff what I wonder
is if there's different types of uh uh
talokins because that nurse uh food
deliverer seemed to be a lot weaker in
that she could be shot by a Sonic Gun
and bleed out versus other people
healing so I'm wondering if uh talokins
are like what you grow into is your is
your job right like are the warriors a
different kind of hearty and like is
that how you decide so I'm since Namor
is the king because of his mutation like
is that his thing that was something
right right um Jamie Lee I ship Namor
and shuri anyway stopping by to send
some love Jeremy Shields music says and
respect you guys loving koi goes on
tangents you're so well spoken my dude
haha he is very well spoken thank you I
would love Coy to become like a person
who also like becomes like an editor and
a thumbnail guy I want to see Kenny can
he keep up this level of I love it I
love that you're like yeah he's really
good at what he does that's what he does
yeah
I will fully own everyone that is both
positively and negatively always like
why doesn't Corey have his own channel
he does he doesn't edit he doesn't make
graphics he's not good at the stuff that
Greg does and Greg is well spoken and
John is well spoken so these guys have a
channel for a reason yeah I am very well
spoken end of list yes it's uh no I
think Coy's I mean our lists are the
same coin and he's a genius man I I love
that you guys appreciate it because I
always feel like there's no place for
the skill set and I have found a place
where I feel at home with reject nation
and it's because of you guys and because
of these guys so thank you fun trying to
make a thumbnail for an hour
all right videos
what is this [ __ ] thumbnail gonna be
yeah also like I swear a lot two hours
trying to figure out what to do and
behind the scenes of boys comic quarter
is me right here Greg sitting right here
going like you can't say that not often
but every so often I should be like
that's not no I do want to hear the
inevitable like loveline-esque like live
podcast where you're the engineer and
you're doing your thing you're doing
your thing and then you just chime in
with some kind of matter of fact
also uh saying koi is well spoken is
racist apparently apparently yeah uh I
like that Bobby let's move on here
um Bobby cool Quetzalcoatl what was your
theater attraction at imperius Rex
Empire King uh I don't think people knew
what it meant not much either in Latin
or in comic context it is it was fun
watching it in a Californian crowd
though because there was like a really
obnoxious white guy um
clearly white it was really obnoxious
see they had the ultimate the silence
it was in the it was he was he was um he
was two rows in front of us and um and
then you know we're in La a lot of
Latino people there and and then at one
point when Neymar got burnt uh when I'm
sure he burned him
for some reason was like
and then if one of the Latino people
like a couple seats from down for me was
like shut your [ __ ] ass off
[Laughter]
[Music]
fidgeting and checking Shazam weirdly he
was shazamming lots during the week but
he was also loving it it was weird the
first half of the movie I was like this
guy is not happy and also feels like
he's at home and then I was like no no
he's way into it strange so what's funny
is like we've all been talking about how
likable neighbor was so the idea of it
being like yeah burned that bad guy the
villain by the the name uh my brother
made a joke when the movie was over as
he was walking out and he was like it
was awful huh like it was just a joke
and then that same guy who seemed like
he hated the movie turned around was
like it was amazing this is a great
sequel he got so defense I was barely on
Shazam that was so good I only took out
my phone sometimes
I cannot imagine taking out my face
he was not watching Zachary Levi by
Shazam it's the first time I've seen
that in a theater where he's like trying
to get whatever the music is this Ludwig
gorinson let me check anyway imperious
Rex is there some comic book Oh that's
oh yeah that's that's his Avengers
Assemble that's the big catchphrase of
Neymar so he goes imperius racks and
attacks uh that's like his his it's not
often you see a catchphrase so
synonymous to the characters that was a
really big moment in the movie what I
thought was interesting was it was a lot
like Avengers Assemble where we had
waited 10 years for Avengers Assemble
and the delivery was the opposite of
what you'd expect like it was more of a
conviction like Chris Evans delivered
that like Avengers assembly it felt like
uh and this was likewise like imperius
Rex didn't feel like a war cry it felt
like him stealing himself up so I was
like oh that's a different
interpretation than I ever would have
thought and I dug that so my theater
went like
chuckle chuckle comic fan comic fan
confusion ah confusion like some type of
Spanish word whatever
[Laughter]
and also he casually just mentions he's
mutant yeah like no questions asked I
mean he maybe is the first because he
might be older than Wolverine right
1600s yeah probably so I like that
because in the comics he's the first
mutant so I think they're going with
that which is cool oh that'd be cool I
would love the mutant uh shuri saying
they abandoned me no clouded memory
clouded memory says all and also I think
uh our knowing was this oh who's our
Riri um
there's the stories I think are uh
Ramona Ramona knowing about I was just
his way to have his cake and eat it too
yes yes Ramona it was the stories way to
have its cake and eat it too with her
death she'll never have a relationship
with her grandson but the audience can
feel comfort knowing that she at least
knew no I think I saw some people bring
it up in the comments earlier I think
she knew before she found Nakia and hate
that's how she knew where Nakia was I
think
um and uh I think she knew before that
and I feel like if she had just found
out like that's that's your son I don't
think she would be like go find go find
it yes
I don't think he I don't think she would
have uh I think like the fact that she
had been a mother for a while I think it
would have changed her decision if she
had learned in that moment because yeah
Nokia is just like I'm staying in the
board I'm fighting now and uh yeah
someone's watching after Prince the
child
and I really like the closure that you
immediately saw shuri get in that her
mom knew I really enjoyed that acting
delivery immediately where she went
through like grief Joy confusion
acceptance and then she also asked the
question then it was like oh she got to
have that she got to have a grandchild
for six years she was so beautiful she
lost her father she lost her brother she
lost her mom she unlike her actual
family she lost but care now she her
family gets to live on with Prince
t'challa yeah it was so beautiful I love
that scene both Phil James G Namor says
he is a mutant yes yeah and the first
one in the comics and now apparently the
MCU glanda
gonz Landa sure he's saying they
abandoned my child they abandoned me
when woo uh family didn't come for her
on the ancestral plane broke my yes and
it broke by her name was saying you're a
queen now was just cold I love that line
you're a queen I'm like that's
yeah and uh I was like I didn't know if
you're a villain yet or not but you're
definitely
you've just graduated from antagonists
you're my understanding of you has gone
down a lot more now um but yeah that was
a great but oh yeah that line too when
she does wake up after the ancestral
plane and um yeah just they're desperate
I thought the fact that they couldn't
like get your seat t'challa they they
work towards the narrative so well and
also the reveal when she punches the
suit
like the way they handled that was great
in camera where you don't see that
coming so even though you know that's
where you get when you take it yeah you
know she's going to be like Panther but
they still gave us a surprise yeah for
you because because I remember the first
time watching I hear a bunch of people
went oh [ __ ] and then you have Nakia
immediately go Oh [ __ ] yeah
that was great that was awesome that was
awesome yeah
um cloudy memory back at it again
whereas with shuri she can now have a
relationship with her nephew a part of
me wonders if this scene was constructed
after all the outrage over t'challa
being killed off in the movie after
Chadwick's death oh it's I don't think
so I think it was from the beginning
yeah I think that was Ryan coogler
wandering honoring t'challa and Chadwick
in that kid being like his he looks so
much like Marvel doesn't seem like the
kind of crowd to play Kate yeah yeah
angry mobs
like you know what would you think
they're the kind of can we poke them we
make Todd hulks we don't placate mobs
Todd Hulk that's that's yeah that's how
many people are dressed up they're one
step away from being like should we just
make a new t'challa no let's not do that
it could have happened three different
um yeah you know David CI yeah it's true
those goofy foot wings that that could
have gone terribly awry but it actually
was uh yes I love the the snake sound to
tie into his like name his God name and
how that felt like Sinister and he has
his women tickle it oh my Devon
pangrikar not enough cameos hated it
where was Toby hey everyone
what is this youth pastor doing
Pizza Time
Pizza time I would love to be delivering
pizza wakanda all right put some sand in
here let's see the stream Labs koi I'm
gonna tag out after streamlab I'll I'll
Boogie I'm gonna see if there's any that
directly thank you koi I love you koi
got you tough acting connect
the koi's got to go we'll stay oh koi
yay but I'm gonna make sure we get if
there's any last ones in here I got you
got the Boogie we got a few we got a
handful oh do we yeah cool thank you koi
yeah of course and I love these folks so
thank you guys for liking my ring I'm
making up for my rant time the five
minutes I ranted uh derailed this I'm
coming back yeah you dick how dare you
don't you can't you tell everyone hates
you when you do that
okay
for teas and passion you're one step
away from being not invited back right
comic going on coming Corner uh here's
what Wikipedia says
oh wow no they do the words like this
the whack what's going on when it's in a
square is it in his head what's a speech
bubble
I do read Comics but my the way I
especially nowadays just with The
Balancing Act is how I read Comics is
like koi what do I gotta read to prepare
for this I'm gonna read all this and now
it's time to move on to the next thing
give me 10 comics I forgot everything I
read I'll read it tonight before the
midnight how it always goes for me is I
just like I forgot but he does read them
which I respect and John asks me a few
months out and then reads a trade or two
and then we all Forget by the time I
think like got even video games gotta
War Ragnarok I'm like oh man I did play
it but I don't remember because I played
it at the time for to prepare for the
trailer and now the trailer's been out
for months now I forgot what happened in
the game
so much content
um yeah that's my life it's just like a
constant it's Lucy with the chocolates
but it's like movies input output output
when I film with koi it is when I watch
when I'm filming with more like I'm here
to monitor a thing uh it is uh
impressive to me because I'll like with
the villains list like we we like got
the list of he posed a great question of
like what's gonna qualify as a film like
what do you mean just get the bad guy
and I was like Oh wait [ __ ] yeah and
then and then if we were like he was
here for like 40 minutes just like going
like I guess because we had to we had to
figure out like what are some and we
missed a few we did like we missed death
dealer crossbones yeah there was a
couple that we did Lee shout out um but
we we decided to um the way we did it
and then koi just for over the course of
40 minutes decided to put it in a
category listed but you know we didn't
have time to re-watch any of these
movies I didn't re-watch I didn't look
up and that was all off the Dome there
wasn't a single note written down that's
normally what I never do notes that's
normally what it is and then the fact
that the way you can talk about it in an
efficient way with barely having to do a
retake is really impressed to me because
I feel like I swear you've just watched
this movie like a day did you just watch
the entire it's really impressive
because you have you have a very
emotional memory I think because I think
that's what memory that memory is
um usually rooted in Emotion that's why
I get so mad at people thinking it's not
as important as real life because it the
emotional resonance is all that matters
like what matters in your life is what
you experience what you choose to
experience it's like kind of like how
the movie says it's not really how it's
why
the movie is
um yeah why is Gamora
Curtis Mason love you guys
I love you too loved the movie and
thought they handled the passing of
Chadwick well I like that they made the
son's name child but curious how the
more hardcore conquer readers feel about
it well there's a movement I also like
King maybe imbaku at the end yeah I I
think it's there's a version of this
that could somewhat satisfy I met the
guy briefly and heard some of his a very
brief I didn't really talk to him about
the actual subject who started the
recast the child movement and he's
actually a really nice guy and and and I
think it's funny when you like listen to
him and you see that his position on the
move it is not at all how it's morphed
into like aggression and anger like it's
actually quite nuanced in the way he
talks about where I'm like no I actually
get where you're coming Zack Snyder nice
guy
she's tired like the the spider version
yeah yeah no totally absolutely
um so yeah no it it is uh it's not if
you've actually go to the root of it the
good things change over time it's like
the word woke it's like like
everything's become telephone like when
you call someone call someone calls like
but like it's a movement
but yeah no I I do think um more
confident I don't know how they're gonna
feel about it but it could be
interesting I like the guy how to play
in his mouth on the culture yeah uh and
kushik you've asked a couple times uh
can you please explain whether silicon
people got revived easily after gunshot
a bridge fight uh they're underwater uh
at all times so their skin would have
more pressure resistance and they've
also got uh regenerative abilities
because they've taken a version of
cancer damn in addition to having an
internal uh regenerative Source in the
heart-shaped which is how shuri is able
to revive herself they have an external
total density as well as an internal
healing fact but okay I'm a big fan of
rules in movies sure
my question though is when
when uh Lake Bell is shooting them
they're going down yeah but they're able
to get back up because they're still
impacts like we're in a bulletproof vest
right you'd still feel the impact it
doesn't mean you don't get hurt but it's
like it's like getting punched versus
getting shot it will still cause you to
be harmed it just won't go through you
and end you but I feel like there were
other times in the movie where they were
getting hit with [ __ ] and they were just
like that's why I was talking it off
briefly earlier about I think there's a
hierarchy of skill like I think there's
also like how the herb interacts with
you that's why I think there are nurses
and there are people that brought the
food she was able to be killed by a
Sonic gun so clearly her skin is more
you know uh malleable sure so I think
that the Warriors are a different type
of talokin that siren scene was amazing
oh dude I love they use like Celtic
myths in the siren like oh it's
beautiful beautiful love you too good to
hear you Curtis that happening too
why are you on my lemon drink
flev Doran flavius it was a very good
flim but it didn't had the same impact
on me like it did for you coming from
flev that's shocking surprised there
were little things that bothered me that
stopped it from being a 10 but I hope
the future spin-offs will show more of
wakanda and learn more about this world
nope no more World building Flav that's
all you get
I'm sorry man flub's usually like I
don't know guys
it's wild okay well sorry fluff
um Ronin Unchained
so ironheart is a cop killer I thought
that too in that scene
when she when she's like I'm creating a
path for you guys and she like like
explodes like the cop cars I'm like
murderer you can definitely look like a
criminal right now
it's an a-cap movie
Ronin Unchained hi again Greg John and
Coy the mid credit scene was my way of
saying goodbye to Chadwick and t'challa
I thought shurin Namor were gonna end up
together for a second surprise no
Avenger went to the funeral even just as
a cameo with no dialogue we never got to
your chat quite late but yeah there was
a reason why why I think it would have
been distracting for The Avengers
um I do think it would have been really
cool if uh yeah sure and the more ended
up just making out and said no more
saying they shouldn't be a fight they
shouldn't fight Make Love Not Wars
Rose in his mouth
he takes her from a number to mi amor
yeah
[Music]
it's located Atlantis are actually two
cities
uh we need The Amalgamated universe so a
nerd chronic added us a mom more seat
all right this next one's good Sarah
says Ken koi please started only fans
name suggestion koi's comic porner
I uh here's a little Wiki feet taste
yeah what are you doing on live stream
running a sweater would you eat bad last
night I did actually
I had my first like actual cheat day
since hugging the Rock and doing two
days and I feel bloated yeah okay up
seven pounds though feel good but uh
yeah so unfortunately with my job being
so public figure-ish uh there is a
slippery slope of what is probably
acceptable by companies I work for I
have considered it in dire times and I
do enjoy
the human body but uh with the job I
want and the job I have it does not seem
appropriate but I appreciate your
wanting it
[ __ ] you still look great you don't
think I uploaded
what's that you're like bloated
calling me out he caught me and nope I
said that bloated but I was like
my live chat's got my back okay honest
opinion I don't even think you look
bloated and absolutely agree Kenneth
Anderson I I did think that the siren
bit added a nice touch of eeriness that
we don't often see in the maku and a
potential like uh psychic attack I did
enjoy that that could lead to some
psionic ability it's beautiful love it
movie is a testament to the master
craftsmanship of coogler he makes us go
through so many emotions for the
character death off screen and not
deviates from the stakes at play the
intro the telecon folks creepy and
goosebumps inducing loved it RL Stein's
black panther yeah that was like a
horror scene yeah and I think he infuses
suspense quite well like I think the
lead up to the fight on the on the on
the freeway when everything's like yeah
we're kicking ass we're getting away and
then
pull went up slow motion again the
silence you know koi is like you step
one you get one step closer I'm gonna
mess you up but because it's silent
you're like I don't think actually has
like I feel I'm there I'm on the bridge
music come on yeah yeah music oh and
then the fight against what con it's
it's it is a bummer the finale fight is
not his although it's like when when
they are going Imam boy like on that's a
moment oh my gosh and when she yells
wakanda forever I'm like I feel this or
even when she attacks tries to kill uh
no more with the language he goes
wakanda forever I was like damn that's
bull yeah also just on a that guy in
front of us when the first wakanda
forever came up he did it and I felt it
through the sea he went
I was like you go white guy
stand up for all of us on a personal
note that bridge is a bridge that I've
walked over a few hundred times uh
connects in Atlanta she says Boston
traffic I I think of you each time yeah
so there's the sicko sign in Boston that
uh is no longer a sign for like oil or
gas it's actually like a landmark like
it's it's been a declared a city
Landmark so there's no gas station
anymore but there's this giant Citgo
sign and she literally lands in front of
at one point the spirit of it because
like that's the most specifically corner
like Niche Boston thing but that bridge
is literally connecting uh there's a
concert venue I used to go go to called
the Middle East upstairs and then the
other side is where I used to live so
that would be the like I'm almost home
drunk Bridge so that would be like the
the light at the end of the tunnel green
light and uh to see them fight on it was
like my drunk bridge is in the MCU like
it just felt felt like home so I loved
that awesome
koi walked the bridge
all righty information on new rock stars
oh wow koi wow I saw crap earlier
they're like oh Chloe's got three places
he feels at home yeah but this audience
is like just the best like I feel at
home I feel like I can go on rants here
because of you lovelies
just be realistic to get a whale
all right koi would it be real got
everybody no
oh my God there's two more I can do two
more
all right flev doran's back I love the
suits call it a guilty pleasure but the
Iron Heart suit looked like an Iron Man
Power Rangers mix yes it did it reminded
me of the old animator shows like Gundam
so that was like a pseudo Nostalgia hit
for me but I understand why people find
it silly well we're finally talking
about that Iron Heart suit I uh you know
that's cool that you can find a way to
appreciate it
um I did not think it looked very good
the the I like the Proto suit the
produce produce great yeah the final one
especially in that like super bright
lighting and the close-ups which is like
I don't like being that guy especially
to these days but yeah it's it's it's
the CG effects Marvel needs to get their
VFX [ __ ] together those people are are
they watching crazy bum listen all 200
credited VFX overpaid yeah
too many people uh I think that uh it's
a step toward the cooler suits they had
to make one that was big and bulky like
it's her mock too but it cost us I think
a really cool reveal because we were
like oh this is what we get she
obviously has to evolve it in her own
show so if they made it to refined and
Sleek now I get why it happened but I
can't disagree that I was like okay yeah
no it didn't look great
um
uh all right look I need to swing to the
bathroom really fast
and then I'm gonna go to the bathroom
and then last question Ecto guy then I
leave
think they will use time travel to make
t'challa Jr older and take on the Black
Panther mantle sooner I personally think
that he will be a young Avenger and I
personally think that we have two Young
Avengers of a similar age and Wanda's
children so I could see it where the
Young Avengers is a great span of Ages
from you know Billy Tommy and Prince
t'challa all the way up to Kate bishop
and that would be an interesting way to
show like maybe they do kamala's law and
they have it so like that kid's adorable
they could be like this kid gets hurt
and that's on you Kate Bishop like she
would have to be an authority figure
even though she's still young so having
really Young Avengers would make it
exactly and that would add a scope to it
other than if they're all like 16 then
you're like well they're almost in
college like you you have a different
like young perspective so I think keep
them young I also think the problem
we've discussed with um you know shuri
just got the mantle she just accepted
this this new version of herself it
would kind of shortchange Sherry's Arc
if they jump him ahead so I think
there's a place for both of them as they
stand now but what I think they might do
is have a time travel element where we
meet Prince t'challa older in secret
Wars or Kang Dynasty I was wondering if
you get that moment without having it
sacrificed some multiversal thing yeah
totally so you meet like a prince
t'challa that's already accepted his
place without sacrificing this young one
yeah totally I feel like yeah it would
be kind of weird to be like we got a new
black panther go sure oh no we're in now
we're not really sure anymore yeah it
would feel strange and I feel like they
they it's a deliberate choice to get the
kid and I doubt that they would want to
go we're gonna introduce this child and
immediately age them up yeah it would
feel very like we don't care about how
you connected to him he's gone now yeah
yeah it wouldn't it wouldn't make for a
good step Stone and as Dynam uh dynamic
as the kid is you wouldn't want him to
lose that innocence in that his his
father t'challa was like I don't want
him to have the pressure of wakanda and
then immediately be like but you've got
the pressure of being the Black Panther
like what what Chadwick leaving leftist
was a moment to resonate on life and
rebirth let him grow into that as
opposed to like personally
I don't see where you're coming from
immediately
what you're saying I know just I'm
honestly rushing the t'challa movement
yeah and just making Baku t'challa too
we need oh Greg wants like five black
panthers everyone takes a heart-shaped
Nakia black panthers get everyone from
Atlanta black panther yes that's why
they ended this I wanted Darius black
panther three Atlanta season five paper
boy who else is actually
zazi beats is the only crossover I think
Paperboy and lazy beats right oh wait no
uh Donald Glover's Hobie and Spider-Man
yes yeah yeah yeah okay so I think the
entire cast except like the lead cast
except La Keith yeah and like Keith want
to be Joker really bad but he had like a
whole food so other than that I think
that all the MCU would be here
okay uh lakeith is uh the only member of
the Atlanta leading cast that's not in
the MCU because we do have more
streamlabs also 130 it is
10 minutes more we go ahead
10
minutes
exhaling Juan
exhaling one says thanks for the
roasting
due to my being a nerd I often say it
the way Greg said it
damn it
I couldn't wait to process the movie
with y'all well you know how much this
movie affected me man thanks for coming
over here I started crying in my
non-spoiler review I had to hold back my
tears as I was talking about it in the
outside the theater's like oh no I'm not
gonna be that guy I'm not gonna start
crying Greg was the guy sobbing loudly
in the theater like look at me crying
everyone watch me be affected this is
for wakanda but you make it about here
at the theater yeah well I like I I had
a weird thing where the first time I saw
it it was at a press screening so it was
a lot of our friends and a lot of like
people we usually talk to after the
movie but I immediately didn't want to
be around anyone yeah I would have hated
it I didn't know I didn't want to talk
to anyone after the movie I went around
the corner and like processed yeah I
didn't and it was the last thing I want
to do also David yeah we'll go back to
the Super Chat that's a problem yes
black panther corals get David in there
I'm into it and a clipping song for a
Black Panther movie oh so cool and Rafa
Cassell as the honorary white wolf
somewhere
to chop her to send a knock you after he
came back from the blip just in case God
forbid something like that happened
again it makes perfect sense also sure
that's a very good point and I also love
how they'll continue to tell stories
throughout his son but right now focus
on shuri I wouldn't mind just one more
but sure he is I could use that because
there wasn't much black panther you know
obviously
um and it should be nice to get another
follow-up where it's like there's a lot
of black panther because there is
something striking and rewarding on your
leg the suit yeah yeah I see it there's
a suit and you have all those motions
tied to the character that's still
replicated in her interpretation of the
Black Panther mantle yeah I think it's
like another movie with her would be
pretty awesome oh I did want to mention
what uh Lapin poke wrote quora said it
is uh the four year anniversary of
losing Stan Lee today oh is it today
today's the four year oh my goodness so
we lost sadly an entire high school or
college career ago which is insane to
think about time is crazy
time rest in peace to the great the one
above all else did you meet him yeah
yeah actually I went to uh they had a
bit of a living wake for him where we
all got to celebrate his life
um in person he got to hear stories from
all the people that really cared about
him and they had like this whole uh
ceremony to honor him while he got to be
there with us
um and it was about a year before he
passed so I got to spend actual time
with him and I got to like do it around
people that came up with him so I got to
hear a lot of stories about him while he
got to live beautiful it was a really
special ceremony that's beautiful that's
lovely yeah I'd like a living wake I
would too like I really hope I ever do
enough to like earn the fact that
they'll be like that kind of ceremony
like I just wanna I want people to I
think we need to tell people we love
them more do it tomorrow living wig guys
kicking it off Saturday compliments
tell me you love me when you can
me
to paraphrase
yes that's why I like birthday so much
uh we read oh you sent it twice no
refunds
Shane
Shane shuri Thor wakanda equals losing
both your parents your sibling and most
of your Nations that's phase four man
lost stories loss and uh and dealing
with loss let's not forget Doctor
Strange Christine Palmer Christine
Palmer yeah that is just as heavy yeah
actually what else was was that was I
mean it was Heavy if you're invest in
the Rachel McAdams character which was
substantial yeah it's the same thing as
a breakup oh 100 a breakup losing your
whole nation yeah I just meant that
movie had a breaking up with your nation
instead of death yeah breaking up with
hundreds and thousands of people
yeah it is the same all right let's go
back to the the supers
yeah she needs to keep getting paid man
very few people will work with people
who are back
it's a reality of the industry right now
yeah
hey got six more minutes of cool you
better make it count yeah yeah we're
making it count we making it count we
make an account lots of great quiet
montages of Chadwick I also agree I love
the way that they use it oh can you guys
hit the like button sorry to interrupt
you hit the like if you're here please
that would help us out especially for
playback
uh please hit the like people will
actually come to the playback if this
pops up somewhere yeah yeah no seriously
the link like buttons do help for that
thing
um Angel
solar I really am happy that three of
you enjoyed this movie
um this is the one I want to Marvel to
get right the most would love to get
y'all a drink one day I would love to
have that drink but for you to just walk
away after a giveness yeah acknowledge
us drop off the drinks and leave say a
nice thing and then but the second you
start making it a conversation I'm
checking out man
uh San Francisco you lovelies I'm gonna
be in San Francisco the Thanksgiving
weekend for San Francisco Fan Expo
uh San Francisco Fan Expo I'll be doing
a real rejects conversation live in
person as well as I'm gonna be sitting
down with the cast of Clerks gonna be
sitting down with cast of Cobra Kai Sons
of Anarchy Ming not win uh like an
incredible weekend Ron Perlman Giancarlo
Giancarlo Giancarlo Esposito uh Theo
Rossi uh from Luke Cage uh you want to
keep going up here I'm just saying
they're great people yes I'm against
Theo Ross but yeah so it's an incredible
Sons of Anarchy too yeah yeah so uh and
wilfredell were having like a one-on-one
conversation with with uh Christy Ramsey
romano and I'm sorry Christy Carlson
Romano and I'm very excited to meet all
of you so anyone that's there please
please hunt me down it's going to be red
yeah for the record we actually really
like when people say hi to us we we will
I I feel like I overstay and I think
people usually want to get out of the
conversation
I feel like people are usually try to
get out of the conversation with me
earlier and I'm like I'm not even trying
to leave but I feel like you want to go
I was really happy to talk to you one
more picture one more picture do you
want to take a picture we took pictures
Greg I'm at work I just said hi I'm
sorry
would you like to pay for the sandwich I
only know you as that reaction guy I
don't even know your name I don't even
know what your name is the internet
right yeah
um
monsters monsters or yeah Mrs
do you think
the Thunderbolts will be sent to wakanda
because of Val bugging the kamoyo beads
I've heard Rumblings at the plot of
the wakanda show involves people
invading the nation of wakanda and it
wouldn't surprise me if that itself
might be ramifications of thunderbolts I
don't know how direct it's going to be
but I do think there's something to this
maybe not as linear but there is
something there
yeah I don't feel like the Thunderbolt I
feel like Thunderbolts probably do
something bad if it'd be like a total
Suicide Squad story like yeah we're
doing something bad but
you know never mind
no not that bad we're not going to but
no that's a fascinating Theory because
there's a reason she's here so I'm
hoping it uh sometimes the connective
threads especially in phase four are not
as evident but I'm hoping it sets up
something important I feel like it's
just mainly for something with secret
animation
maybe Val's a scroll that's oh that'd be
fun I'd like that especially since we
found out they were married in this
movie which would be a fun like personal
yeah right because they have history and
there's Investments see how important
the Everett Ross plot line is true dude
Everett's everything for a potential bp3
what would you all want the most for the
plot Tariq acchawa uh no of what I would
want for the plot of that
oh I'd like to see imbaku juggling being
the king and the difference in what the
Black Panther mantle means when the king
and the protector are separate and I'd
like to see the people of wakanda
dealing with a new kind of black panther
like what it represents to the people
and then her having to you know kind of
like weigh that new new weight of
responsibility that's a difficult answer
at the top
I feel like that will not I will not top
it that would be good to have a Baku get
that shine as well you know yeah for
sure
I'd like an army of Everett Ross's
there's an option for more Martin
Freeman because uh yeah uh Chris Mann
really wanted to get this one out oh
before I leave okay the streamlabs yeah
yeah off topic but I'm a straight man
and koi genre makes me question uh
things I would also pay for a koi fan
site you know man as as a man who
appreciates a compliment as we discuss
toys coital Corner no higher praise the
koi's coil Corner let's do it
unfortunately there will be no fan site
but you have warmed my heart with your
appreciation as a straight man with
questions and the women that met chimed
in earlier as well just starts that
needs to be an orientation straight man
with questions
and that is the perfect place to go
much love rejection thank you so much
and again San Francisco 25 26 27 I will
be all over Fan Expo so you have if
you're in San Francisco or can be in San
Francisco Fan Expo their lineup is
stacked uh we might be doing a ton with
them going forward and we're doing the
first live reject conversation with me
up there so uh please please please
please please please please please get
up there and that is the start of things
to come so keep keep an eye out from
Greg and Rags again scheme some stuff uh
but yeah we got some we got some cool
stuff team scheming all right much love
y'all I'll see you very soon to get us
to Missouri yeah I feel like there's no
cons held in Missouri I'd go to Missouri
and uh no one really cares about
Missouri it's a fine place it's hard to
spell uh that's where I want to go I
want to go to the projects of Detroit
Michigan I've never known Detroit it's
always been on my list
um and then now I want to go no gyms
from Detroit to um South Dakota
Starlin uh Thanos was born in Detroit so
it's a historic comic place I'm also
thinking maybe the Kansas City
just trying to find just play so many of
these places have Comic Cons don't they
but we're gonna run them you know what
we're gonna make them we're gonna put
them on the Lights
100 people go to
let's go to like a basement con Texas is
over popular now you should they also
have like five cons out there we'd be
we'd be overrun overrun those five cons
would take us trying to dominate a space
where we're guaranteed at least 50
people we want to be the biggest fish in
the smallest Bowl we gotta fly out there
we gotta make sure that bowl is small
for us yeah see there are parts of Utah
maybe not Salt Lake but definitely parts
of Utah that would be worth it if anyone
in the checking guarantee us an audience
of 45 to 50 people it's good enough
we'll be at Zion National Park just come
find us there yeah it gets twelve
dollars you gotta get that play we gotta
make that happen yeah yeah yeah all
right you lovelies get to San Francisco
I'll see you there always a pleasure
guys love you guys
how do you go that's why I do called
yeah
it makes me happy every time I hear it
all right let's readjust the frame a tad
bit here buddy
it's okay though
I think a tiny bit to do anything on
this right now so all right perfect we
have been readjusted we are at just a
month adjustment oh my God the new
rockstars breakdown's 40 minutes
I hope there's a 10 minute ad in there
we can cut out yes
20 minute ad
it's mostly an ass that's the funny part
about when we do those breakdowns is
that um it would cover like a reaction
because like obviously the hard part is
their end of putting that together if
the team of editors and boss and all
them
um and then for us it's like I'd be like
a two-hour edit
to be a set of spending days
yeah so it's not like that much on all
right but it's just still like still two
hours
um but yeah no I appreciate that they
let us react to their [ __ ] though that
means a lot um and I know a good amount
of those new rock stars people know a
good amount of them boss included
I'm friends with Eric Boston uh it's
crazy
um voice inject embaku chomping on the
carrot with chef's kiss let's love that
the secondary Anders everyone just
laughs so much yeah
I wonder whose choice that was too
because it's because it's it's a
specific enough carrot like I don't even
know if it's like a legit you know it
might be like an offshoot of you know
like it looks like something that
probably grows locally and he just
picked up and so part of me goes that
had to have been like an intentional
call by somebody but then it also just
feels very much like oh to be in the
carrot in this scene see how it goes you
know
man no we we got it I feel like I think
we missed the Thor love and thunder
breakdown I think that's not like we
should do the new rock stars one yeah
black panther definitely merits it you
think so
damn you know what and I wanted to show
um wait let's do it normally we stream
for like four hours but I'm like if I
need to end it a little bit early I'll
see we'll see how we feel what are you
doing koi is back for new rock stars
also uh in the comic books Baku is Man
Ape and carrots are beloved by ape so it
was a nod to his comic book counterpart
I I'm so happy that that that piece
thank you thank you clarified thank you
koi
night Captain let's move on here Captain
why do you think shuri saw killmonger
they explain it pretty clear in the
movie of why sure he's not killmonger
because of she she he was even saying
that you're you practically requested
that it was me that you talked to
because her current mental and emotional
state and the goal that she
subconsciously really wants where she's
really at in life is more akin to
killmonger and so it's kind of getting
like an affirmation or a motivation like
some type of being validated validated
yeah yeah and I think him confronting
her saying like oh you didn't think this
the the ancestral plane actually existed
do you lends even more Credence to the
fact that the subconscious would have
brought him you know through those means
exactly and still that's such a
brilliant scene such a standout scene
absolutely it's leaked all over the
internet if you guys want to watch it
yes piracy let's do it
thank you tins people tend to attract
others who are the same but both of you
are positive amazing I am intense around
here so people who are also that
gravitate toward towards you all koima
stretched a lot of Golden Retrievers as
that man is pure joy yeah I mean gotta
beat him off of him every time he comes
around I think it's it's a concerted
effort to be positive and grateful but
we're all very human and we can get very
negative and very stressed and and
anxiety and and uh Angry and there's a
so yeah you know it's like the like on
this channel I've made the intentional
effort to like dial back some more of
those like because once in a while we do
some video that might be a little bit
more on the negative leaning
um but I've made a potential effort to
dial that back because I hated the
feeling of that um
even though it's way easier to get views
on this I'm alive it is so much easier
but I was like I just don't like the way
it makes me feel and then because for
example like I I did I would we would
talk so much about Ezra Miller off
camera that I felt like okay to talk
about that situation on it but then it
got to a point where like so many things
were coming out
that I just felt like we'd just be
repeating ourselves yes the same video
with a different crime or just like a
couple different sentences yeah just
like there's no point in doing it like
sure it'll get views but at the same
time I'm like I don't we don't really
talk about it anymore off cameras
there's no point in us talking about it
so it just didn't feel especially when
it's like something that's a little bit
more of a drama or negative subject for
example like crapping on YouTube I did a
video about that recently and I'm like
I've never been in like over a year uh
but yeah you know so we just try to do
it this movie was so cynical it was dark
it was Bleak I want to call it cynical I
wouldn't call it cynical at all it's
dark and Bleak and harrowing but now I
want to call it cynical
um
Marco Tunstall what were your thoughts
when nemour called himself a mutant I
literally applaud it sorry if we talked
about this I had to leave for a bit no
worries at all
um I like to come back we did talk about
it quite a bit uh John Munch take it
away yeah I mean it's uh it's a in fact
I don't think I actually fully heard the
line the first time uh but yeah I love
how casually it is thrown out but I
think that's probably what Eric Voss was
even pointing to when he was like you
know there's one little thing that
re-contextualizes so much for the past
and future and uh and yeah especially if
they are going with the comic book
origin then he is like the first mutant
I think that's really cool like it it
doesn't overshadow the movie it doesn't
you know take focus and go X-men guys
but also you know it is another
promissory on the heels of like Miss
Marvel and things like that those are
that mutants are nigh very much so yeah
and uh yeah I thought it was a good
movement I thought it was well handled
it was choice
how do I log into streamlabs on this
computer John do YouTube yeah through
YouTube and then it's the uh the main uh
Channel account yeah
ignite Capitan Namor should team up with
wakanda and as Guardians ooh there you
go have an ally in the land
I think and I guess it's gonna be doing
that right sure man I mean I could
definitely see that happen or be
battling each other
it'll
just be another look on a forever they
show up at new Asgard they're like hey
help us take on the surface world and
they're like oh no let's just kind of
Ally ourselves and then they'll fight
and then eventually they'll agree to be
allies yeah but yeah I mean it would
make a lot of sense
I think that would be cool
plus then you could have uh you know
Namor and uh Thor butt heads get some
arrogance going if only koi was here now
or why for more of the no more air
against you uh raccoon shampoo did you
have trouble buying that telecom had the
size and power to actually fight against
I'm gonna say wakanda and win I feel
like the threat they were said to pose
didn't match up the depiction we saw of
telecon we we don't see in talocon
they're numbers but I got a good sense
for like when they come back like the
one thing the barge fight did do for me
was I was like it does seem like the
wakandans they were about to lose
they're about to lose yeah
about to lose and the more shows back up
and he's like okay everyone stand down
but it's like you know even if the
wakandans are making some Headway or
getting some blows in it it seems pretty
clear that Nemours forces are just so
fast yeah and he even says that at one
point and I kind of trust that line was
you know you know we've got something
about you know more soldiers than than
you could ever even imagine and uh and
yeah so I thought they communicated that
pretty succinctly yeah I think they were
I mean I would have liked to have seen a
little bit more of them like I do think
that final fight especially could have
been fleshed out better especially to
see like two very different fighting
styles clashing with each other would
have been really cool in a smooth camera
way that where the choreography was
really defined because I think you you
do have very different fighting styles
with them and and I would have just
wanted to see that be demonstrated more
but it kind of just called bleeds
together it's a bit of a mess well I
think it could have been cool if they
really took advantage somehow of like
it's
it's a naval battle and if they had
really made it a naval battle somehow I
think that could have been cool whereas
it's mostly people punching each other
on or around a boat yeah a barge
um but yeah you know
I think they still uh communicated the
threat Fray girl hi will the
Thunderbolts be uh first mission be to
take out Everett Ross we need the whole
team to Autumn down I love the idea of
this like affable Everett Ross just this
dude who happens
I'm just trying to stay out of trouble
but I keep getting into trouble I'm just
trying to help my friends just trying to
do the right thing and now I gotta
coming after me the whole team yeah I
want that that's the movie I think
you're kind of work in a funny comedy
there's like a funny spy comedy to do
for Mid fugitive spy movie get smart
especially with like Everett Ross being
married
ex-wife uh being Val yeah that is so
that that would it would be like a
personal thing for her to take him down
I would love that Miss Eleanor I'm going
to say sending some love to the real
rejects thank you Benoit Pride uh yeah
love right back I think we get a
midnight angels in Deadpool versus Doom
oh interesting definitely do you mean
that one that one movie that like one
movie you would do it in
just every Deadpool movie The Midnight
Angels show up to fight him
and they just can't win they just can't
beat them I think a Midnight Angel show
would be cool but I don't I'm not a fan
of the suit personally I would be
waiting for them to get back into the
dorm Elijah gear the suit the the
Midnight Angel suit didn't bother me the
first time I watched it because I was
like oh no no this is a it's like a
protective gear for for the fight
because we saw what akoya had a deal
with and I do like the line when akoye
does eventually come around to the suit
and says how many she says something
like how many do you have or how many
can you build something like that and
where she's implying like I want to give
this to more to the door milage to to
equip Us in battle so contextually I
like the idea of the suit it's just
really the design that I want it to be
well put uh Corey M for Mega extreme a
nice little moment that I liked is that
uh uh a nice little moment I liked is
when Sherry mentions that t'challa
taught her what she knows about science
also need a name or movie and I guess
maybe he taught her about combat too
yeah that's true I mean everything else
that you could do I was surprised by
that because too I was like I don't
really associate t'challa with science
but I guess sure yeah I would have in
maybe because I always thought it was
like t'challa relied on shuri for the
science yeah and then and then he had
you know the the muscle and all that
stuff and the fighting ability and and
you know was the leader but uh sure you
know or at least maybe he set her on the
path maybe he taught her you know the
the foundations
raccoon shampoo overall really liked the
movie felt like a return to the best of
the infinity Saga also the theater gave
us 30 dollars in freaking session oh my
god
wow okay that's a that's a hey that's a
way to to compensate for [ __ ] up your
screening man that's amazing small
popcorn for everyone
that theater food is overpriced but you
get pretty good deals at AMC yeah man
those five dollar rewards you get a
bunch of and then the upgrades to large
uh I like AMC uh further concessions
even though I can only get like two
things I used to get hot dogs
yeah I remember one time leaving AMC
they were running they were like we're
closing at the theater and we got a
bunch of hot dogs left over you guys
want them and I got like 10 hot dogs
I ate all those hot dogs they were so
good that's what that moment is for so
good what are you gonna find 10 people
who need a hot dog I do I think out of
all the meats that I miss it would be a
hot dog
like a Costco hot dog or a wiener
schnitzel used to love Wienerschnitzel
I like their chili dogs okay but no the
Costco Costco
giant juicy hot dog they do it they know
what I mean
when you have your one meat sheets and
make yourself incredibly sick in this
life
there's something about a theater hot
dog I love Nora from Miami she's
complimenting John and she talks about
her toilet it's just like at the time it
was fine and then you're like you're
[ __ ] gross Greg
I too have eaten 10 hot dogs
for free
it's years ago
well yeah if you're getting 10 free
theater hot dogs that's like a 400 value
so you take the free theater yeah oh
yeah there's like eight dollars for some
reason and they laugh they're like two
bites and it's like almost a hundred
dollars they're delicious though um
anyway they are comically large oh it's
like koi stop going off tangent in my or
off tangent searches
America cotton love the movie it ranks
right after infinity war end game in BP
one uh waited here Rihanna song in
cinema and did she kill and give another
layer yeah it's I oh my God yeah what a
beautiful song you know I haven't
actually taken the time to really absorb
the lyrics yet but I think mood wise it
fits so perfect and uh it it did strike
me you know because eventually the
credits do say by Rihanna and I was like
oh yeah [ __ ] this is Rihanna's song and
she came back after like a long time now
I haven't released music for it and it
is with Johnny Depp did she do music she
did something which I ended up I don't
know oh that's right yeah yeah I heard
about this controversy briefly but uh
but yeah no I think this song is nice
and I mean you know songs made for
movies are always a little it could go
either way but I thought this one the
sentiments of the lyrics match really
well without being too on the nose and
also just the sound of the song is
really uh lovely and
um
ethereal and and it sounds a lot like
aspects of the movie and uh is the
production is really crisp it's nice to
hear a credit song that sounds like it
could have actually been in the movie
itself yeah yeah yeah for sure there's a
lot of times those like songs don't and
it's cool to have a song with lyrics
versus just
um orchestral yeah you know yeah and
it's one of the few times where it's
like you know a song is made for a movie
and I feel like sometimes at least to me
that kind of leads to an anticipation
like I'm gonna hear it in the movie and
then you hear it in the credits and
you're like oh it's the credit song but
this is like no this is this is the song
to end the movie on it's the mood yeah
that's a great
um intermission between end credits and
post credits for sure so yeah I I do
appreciate that song a lot Jay recast
cuckoo con with Martin Freeman he can
give coin here
yeah man I didn't see that
Ross oh that's great I like it we'll
start the petition now recast cuckoo con
uh motasum Moto Mommy I think wakanda
show will be named midnight Angels
certainly seems like that's where
they're uh
um leading up to with with um because I
thought it would be like just because I
think the early report or rumor was that
it would focus on the door of melange
but I think to
um don't worry I'll make sure koi sees
your joke Jake don't worry
um but yeah I think um I think I think
it would probably be a Midnight Angel
show I mean they flat out say the suit
is called the Midnight Angel yeah and in
terms of starting a new direction for
wakanda oh it makes it makes sense and
then the way they tease it like she's
doing an action that is not even Within
wakanda
out in somewhere in the US I don't know
where it is but somewhere in the U.S
helping out with with Everett Ross
um I think they are going to be doing a
Midnight Angel specifically Focus show
but I really do hope they update the
suit
and so it's kind of weird like every
time she talks she has to like open the
mask up yeah that computer
which everything every mask now is
yeah I don't know there's something I
think that's
I don't want this to be the complaint of
the MCU of like everyone's becoming an
Iron Man or everyone can be an Iron Man
so almost I almost wish they would maybe
split I don't know it works against the
fact that you know what contest
technology is so Advanced that like they
have to be amazing state of the art blah
blah but I almost wish there was
something a bit more tangible and a bit
less completely technological it's like
when they're using the suits I just
don't believe as much that like the
person in the suit matters as much right
right uh but you know I'm sure they can
figure something out but to go back a
little bit so I know I realized we
didn't really answer your question oh
yes
um I think
um no no
um or Angel uh I keep saying my my
default to say angel midnight Angels
team with Deadpool to try to take out
Doom in the comics that's why they asked
um I don't think that's what we'll be
doing I feel like that I don't think
Logan and Deadpool hook up with the
midnight angels and go take on Doom and
he never meets The Fantastic Four I'm
curious to see what they do do a
Deadpool going down the road because yes
he has he's a very specific pocket of
the movies and and the kind of movie
that that he exists in I am wondering
though when they do start Crossing him
over more with you know characters you
take more serious within the actual
Marvel Cinematic Universe not not just
Wolverine from the former universe but
like the actual moral Cinematic Universe
what um will they be able to adopt some
storylines where you you can take some
stuff a little more serious with
Deadpool in there you know and I think
if you're gonna have Doom in there
they're gonna want more something more
serious absolutely and and so yeah I
don't think they're gonna do a midnight
Angels team with Deadpool thing that
sounds fun and all that sounds like a
what if Episode but yeah that's probably
your best case scenario at that point
but Deadpool and what if would be
amazing yeah I would love for them to do
that that'd be incredible oh dude I mean
I feel like that's gotta that's gotta
happen yeah uh raccoon shampoo do you
think that some of the unfulfilled phase
six unfilled phase six timeline might be
populated by phase four sequels like
eternals two or Xiang Chi 2 or are they
saving those for the next Saga
um I mean I could imagine that just
because it seems like it's enough it
will have been enough time that it will
seem
you know not all of these sequels come
out a couple years after but I feel like
for the new characters especially I mean
eternals 2 is up in the air right now
and that whole thing
I think uh command on Johnny was just in
the news talking about like oh yeah
Patton said a thing but I think he was
just reading a random article no one's
really talked to any anything about an
internals too yet so who knows but uh at
least a Shang Chi too perhaps you know
and especially with Destin Daniel [ __ ]
being so instrumental I guess that's the
main question I have is I feel like he
would they would want and and probably
he would want to come back to do a
shangchi too so if he's doing the
he's doing King Dynasty or is he doing
Secret Wars King nasty he's doing Kang
Dynasty so
I don't know I mean it seems like a
massive undertaking to do those two so
close together
um but I could imagine at least one of
these be having a follow-up in phase six
that's fine we don't really
people are always excited about like the
new movie but we don't really hear too
even though the sequel the direct
sequels do well
they're usually the last ones on my mind
like oh yeah a part two to Shang Chi
part two for eternals well that was kind
of what it was like in the early phases
yeah like Iron Man
Thor like the sequels to these first
movies like how's that going to feel
moving forward after Avengers and now
it's always about like the new character
the new character the new character and
we did it but we did technically have
sequels It's just sometimes it's hard to
big
before I think what I'm trying to get at
is like what's interesting about Black
Panther O'Connor forever is that even
though the in-between was the tragic
death of Chadwick Boseman and they've
been working off of that is that
um it still feels like a part two it
still feels like this is Black Panther
part two and with Dr Strange Multiverse
of Madness I don't really consider like
even though it is I don't really view it
in the lens of this is Doctor Strange
part two
this is Thor love and thunder Thor this
is Thor part four you know because it it
takes on so much about what's happened
in between with spin-offs or the other
movies they appeared in that it doesn't
quite feel like this is this this I feel
the sequel to that franchise yes the
sequel to this entire sequence so I
think having you know after because even
though they kept it on with Iron Man
three in phase two I think
adopting removing that and adopting
subtitles in their in their titles
um is actually very beneficial for the
framework of it I don't know it's
something I don't think
I've never really thought about it until
right now but I think that that is
something that actually does help with
moving forward and stuff like like it's
not going to be called eternals 2
probably it's probably not going to be
called chongqi and the legend the ten
rings too yeah you know it's probably
gonna call it something different shanxi
with a different subtitle you know the
kernels of the different subtitle um
well I almost feel like well I guess
Iron Man is the main one that did
numericals right because the rest of
them I feel like the further you get and
the more it is subtitle the more it
feels like it's yeah more about I almost
it's like we introduce new characters
but I almost feel like you know what
we're really doing is like new situation
you know it's sort of like what the real
progression of sequels is now so I think
the boundaries of like this character
needs a direct movie sequel doesn't
necessarily hold as much water but there
will definitely need to be some kind of
Shang Chi focused follow-up or whatever
I feel like shanxi would certainly get a
sequel direct but like eternals I feel
like we would get another thing with
them heavily but maybe not and eternals
to just them yeah given how the first
movie went over you know yeah and
there's not much like that different in
because it's called Black Panther
wakanda forever too as I find
interesting because
it's it's not like called Black Panther
the dawn of Neymar or something you know
like the next Black yeah yeah oh yeah
Guardians does do the volumes that's
right oh that's right I got like that
that's something there is something that
feels weirdly
more special and more focused when you
have like the the numeric side of it
yeah you know it feels like it's it's
this character next chapter yeah where
is yeah whereas the subtitle plays into
the fact that it is like a big sequence
and this sequel isn't just a sequel to
Thor you know the Ragnarok or whatever
it is it's also the sequel to yeah like
you said the greater circumstances and
stuff that's happened in other movies
that maybe involved Thor but isn't Thor
so yeah but Thor of the Dark World could
feel like Thor too it did but Thor
Ragnarok did not feel like like throw
three yeah it definitely felt like the
next sequel in this phase yeah yeah yeah
for sure and it happens to Star Thor
um yeah
um thank you love watching you guys it
makes me better for me do you see young
child being part of the Young Avengers
or how do you see him in MCU
I mean I I feel like the the obvious
direction would be that I mean the two
main things I've heard
is that through something with Secret
Wars there could be some type of time
Jump where you do have him like aged up
or he would be Young Avengers and I feel
like Young Avengers would probably be
the the way to go for this I do want to
see the movie though where like like for
black panther 3 where a few years have
passed maybe it's not like right after
black panther book on it forever but a
few years have passed perhaps like a
teenager or something who decides to go
into wakanda and you watch him deal with
that where it's kind of like mirroring
in a way of what killmonger dealt with
but end up more positive way
it's not like I gotta take over but how
do I assume the throne I am the rifle
Heir too yeah and how do I really
connect with my roots yeah being yeah
having grown up without them for a
certain period of time yeah I think that
would be because yeah they're like like
Dixon was just saying there that they
think there'll be a huge time Jump but I
feel like it might just be a few years
and you could do that because I you know
it's like if you do a huge time Jump for
young t'challa that they're doing a huge
time Jump Then from Baku and for sure
and all the other characters in the
Black Panther movies uh this is then I
feel like you just create kind of a big
problem for yourself yeah when you do
something like that unless they just
immediately want to get rid of Sherry
but I feel like they want to have sherry
be black panther at least one more movie
yeah that would make sense and just make
him the guy in the chair yeah he moves
to New York meets Spider-Man there you
go uh nerds only
for someone who is coming to this type
of content Creation with breakdowns
reactions I mean it's probably you guys
and Cosmic wonder what advice would you
give beef he's too awesome as well too I
think uh you gotta just
uh it's really easy when you're doing
this to fall into the Trap of like
what's this other person doing how do I
just copy how they do it
um and sometimes you gotta find your own
spin on it it's like I knew okay
Thursday every one of these breakdown
people are posting a post credits video
and I would like to do I want to chime
in too and I know everyone's gonna be
posting their postgres video that day
and uh for us it was like I know if I
put post credit scene breakdown and he
explained it's not gonna really go
anywhere so what's our version of that
let's just lead with our the strong
opinion that we have about it and let
that be the thing and we did that with
Black Adam too I'm like okay now people
are because that's more us that's more
authentic to US versus being like post
credit scene breakdown because I'm like
that's not really what we're doing you
know we're not like like it's a part of
it you know it is but it's not like a
scripted out it's not that you know it's
just off the Dome and more coming from
the emotions so um but that's what I
mean like that and that took me some
time to figure out like what is the
different way how do we talk about this
as we want to without feeling like we
have to call it ending explain post
credit scene breakdown like you know we
might throw those keywords in there to
help out but it's not but we what we
lead with is not about that you know
that's it seems like a smart call
because then you yeah you're in the
arena of that conversation but you're
not doing the same kind of video
everybody else is you present an
alternative discourse yeah I know I'm
not saying we're not the ones who I
don't feel like we're the ones who
really started this but we try to give
the extra layer of for the just watched
you know like bringing a camera bringing
a microphone like doing like the extra
step uh for that and and putting a
full-on edit for it but yeah that was
another thing like the just the movie
reviews no one was ever really watching
so I was like what's the spin on this
for that is more authentic to us that
would help and I was like I feel like
it's got to be in some form of just an
immediate like opinion based reaction so
we're not going to record ourselves in
the theater so what's the next best
thing we can do
risk having security tell us to leave
every single time
conversation which can mess with the
actual being able to talk about it
because it's always the back of my mind
that like any second but it was more fun
to do it that way so yeah I think just
finding finding whatever way you can
make it your your own even if it's
similar in some way that that's the real
way to do it
uh Ismail Montoya hey guys I like black
panther what kind of throw but I felt
crowded is it assumed that embaku
challenged shuri for the throne no no no
I wonder why people are saying that
because I feel like he made it pretty
clear that she's not going to be joining
us otherwise he would be challenging her
otherwise it would have come out and be
like I'm challenging shuri and then
there would have been a joke of like
we're sure cut to Haiti if it was
challenging Siri would they would show
us that he would sure he would they
wouldn't leave us this room to question
and he and he wouldn't say she won't be
joining us yeah yeah I I took that as
she dropped him off essentially yeah on
her way yeah yeah yeah yeah so
um that's no that's that's not all
what's happening yeah it just seems that
is clearly maybe sure he doesn't want to
do the ruling she just wants to do the
panthering and hey my counsel and my my
essentially surrogate now brother you
take it on yeah we can have a close
discourse
health solar Soler would the child
situation not fall under keeping him
from the pressure of the throne the less
people that know equals less conflict to
take the throne sure I don't think shuri
would would be like I could get this kid
out of the way I don't think it would
turn into house of the Dragon horns like
oh no male air what do I do but uh yeah
you know yeah the less people to know
certainly yeah the less conflict the
less you know just the less he has to
have that in his mind from anybody but
but I think at a certain point he's
going to want to assume I think that was
the whole point of saying like do you
want to know my secretary Prince like
he's he's embraced that he's Prince
t'challa yeah he's he's embraced that he
doesn't he doesn't want to already at a
young age and I think Nokia wants him to
embrace that it's just not go into it as
like some type of Game of Thrones
situation you know like does it matter
if you're five years old you gotta be
king you're the king now get it going
yeah so come up with some policy yeah
yeah I'm gonna melt this Crown onto your
head Jay Ali namotor's fight scenes were
flight scenes were Beast yeah they were
awesome they were pretty sick they they
really managed to to overcome that idea
of maybe it'll be silly with the ankles
a lot of the aerodynamic like working
off of the aerodynamic ways when he does
like the hopping though
thrust is really awesome really cool
yeah it's like a control over the
over the air in a way you know Airbender
it's air bending right yeah yeah yeah
Sam Bravo Namor gave me big Magneto
Vibes and I loved it
that's right man he was here for his
people
um I think yeah in a lot of ways yes I
like his motivation a lot in this movie
magnemore I think I I like it a lot no
we're going to be watching that new rock
we're going into new Russian watch
that's 40 minutes long that's an epic
practice breakdown right now epic
breakfast at Big Breakfast Sarah
Campbell oh thank you Sarah that's so
sweet of you thank you for popping in to
say hello and I hope uh you mean you
haven't seen the movie yet I hope you
haven't heard anything conversation I
hope you stopped in to say hello and
left promptly some people don't care
about spoilers and uh yeah you know I
mean fair I I know we both do I think if
you don't care about spoilers
but like I wouldn't like if I do a video
that has spoilers
you know it's I try to let people know
there's spoilers in it but I think the
thing is like I don't tweet out a
spoiler sure yeah yeah you just be
scrolling that's not cool get it all
right there yeah it's it's like if
people come to the video they they know
what they're getting into there's
nothing here
yeah we got to do the new rock stars
video we do
just gotta finish these last uh yeah we
gotta honor the people who have
contributed here tomorrow not gonna lie
I most definitely was rooting for
Neymar's death because that imagery of
Ramona's head floating in that water was
still burned in my mind Hey fair I feel
like that's a cool thing because I did I
didn't agree with the dude clapping when
when it looked like he might you know
get crisped but at the same time I do
like that it is a character that still
allows for something of a mixed reaction
especially when you do accounts for his
actions and the things he is directly
and indirectly responsible for
hey whoever's here if you haven't left
the like yet please go ahead and do that
leave it we're gonna be done and uh I'm
assuming in like 10 to 15 minutes David
hollering yeah yeah probably there
aren't a ton left all right David holler
AKA Legion hey guys sorry it's me again
never apologize is there any chance of a
legion reaction now knowing you haven't
seen it on this channel or on patreon
uh this is big maybe it's a big movie uh
Dan Stevens boy it really comes down to
time you know
um the thing is is not I don't really
like to concern people or put this out
there too much because I feel like just
the context like the Optics around it
can sound like
they could be taken in a negative way uh
and I don't like to put that out there
because I just don't want it to be
received that way and because it's not
so there are plenty of days though
especially in the last month and a half
you know because like as much as we can
get like editing help
um a lot of the times there are days
where you know I'm I'm like just this
week alone there was like several days
where I was like man I've been at it for
like 15 to 17 hours and it could be very
tiring so really that's why we don't
take on too many shows anymore right now
just because it's like a lot of times it
really has to be worth it in the end
because it's like anything we commit to
it's going to take several hours to put
together and uh you know if it's not
really like doing that well then it's
like man but we're committed this we're
gonna finish that yeah so yeah and it
got to a point where like that didn't
really matter as much but it does matter
uh after a certain point you're like no
it does have to count for something
where it's like we're enjoying it and it
is more people are watching it you know
so like a good number word to compensate
for this commitment you know so that's
why because it's like yeah the actual
like
watching something is and and talk and
like doing the doing the reaction in the
review is is way less time than the
actual
like an hour and a half of that is way
less time than the actual prep of it on
uh afterwards so yeah that's that's
that's really the only reason why indeed
but excited to see the show nevertheless
chaos which thank you for the momentio
Omar Banuelos you guys are awesome I've
been a fan of your channel since 2015.
thank you keep up the good work and can
you please give a shout out to me and my
boyfriend angel hello angel hello how
long have you guys been together that's
beautiful yeah always happy to shatter
the happy couple yeah love you both and
thank you so much for watching for that
long hope you hope that actually sounds
like it could be possible thank you
even my favorite channels and I want to
do a video about ranking my favorite
YouTube channels
um and even them like I don't I don't
see I I would never say I've seen all
your videos like there's no way like I
for sure missed it's like many but even
for my favorite channels you know
so thank you for watching that long yeah
shouts out to the both uh feel good
sports and philosophy why do some people
get so excited about another about
either crapping on a movie or it's
perceived flopping it's so weird and
pathetic
some I don't know I mean people humans
tend I think there's a certain aspect of
the human personality that likes to pick
a carcass uh of some degree or another
and it can be fun to join in the shared
momentum of you know figuring out what's
wrong with something you know it's like
there's I think a greater impulse
sometimes to be like
ah this is terrible look at this you
know and uh and yeah I think it's just a
human thing I feel like generally Among
Us I feel like it's more fun to yeah
discuss what you like or to
constructively figure out what could
have been better rather than just
crapping on something and that's just a
personal taste I think uh there's a
tendency in the human psyche to want to
sometimes it feels like if I tear this
person down
or tear this thing down
I can I feel better about it uplifts it
lifts me up in some way
and uh I feel like we kind of do that on
a bigger scale like we like to watch
things fail like there's this thing
where people have it in them where
that's when I say we I'm not saying us
or everyone I'm saying like there's
there is that part of a lot of people
where
it feels like in some way they're being
lifted up and because this other person
or thing has been brought down now yeah
you feel like you're in something of a
power position when really it's not
this is like the the movie success is
nothing and we're talking about
specifically a movie it has nothing to
do with you you know yeah I think it's
the same and people like to feel like
they're right if they thought a movie
was going to suck or or they want to see
something fail and that's usually an
indication that they're not really doing
much with their lives Yeah Yeah the more
you rather people to not do as well the
more you rejoice in the downfall the
more I think you gotta ask yourself why
yeah yeah I've always been more of a fan
of if you can Light One Candle in the
room you know and that's that's more
powerful and strong
so
yeah well I won't deny it though I do
like once in a while if I really don't
like something
I can't get weirdly excited about it
you're like it's gonna be a fun fun
review I can't deny that yeah like once
in a while but I even in those videos I
still I feel like we'll still make the
the effort to like point out what we did
like and what we did think worked and
and explain it rather than just throw it
out throw it away like explain why we
liked it and why that was good yeah
um but you know sometimes it can be fun
but there's a difference in like
oh [ __ ] you versus we're having fun
taking the piss out of it yeah and it's
a proportional thing yeah there's a
difference there every once in a while
that's okay and you know certain times
you'll see something and you'll get the
you'll you'll take a sense of like I
don't think I don't like the attitude
being presented to me by this and
seemingly the people who made it so
sometimes that kind of bridges a gap too
yeah yeah like vulture and morbius that
was so fun to crap on that yeah because
that's like you know
yeah yeah where you're like this doesn't
hold to the Integrity of this movie you
know we can rip this well I'm not gonna
go on camera be like what Sony did is
preposterous
you know like it's not that big a deal
it's just kind of funny to rip about
yeah Daniel kalu's character is in
prison uh Angela Bassett uh says it uh
when she's talking to Okoye about her
husband being in prison
and she can go visit him where she can't
visit her people uh who have passed on
best name the more dialogue even in the
depths of the ocean I brought the sun to
my people very Prometheus beautiful
moment absolutely
such so so dreamlike so Theory I loved
it yeah I thought it was great all the
television stuff yeah because and some
people felt like they didn't get enough
time to get invested in the people of
talocon and
I felt like they were trying to make up
with that with a mood and atmosphere and
seeing that because when you're seeing
the people of talocon
at first
they're just the Assassins they're
they're the Warriors that you're seeing
and the more and then when you go to
telecon you're like oh there's like
families and kids and Happy People life
happy people like there's a lot of
it is a civilization and that was enough
for me to be like oh yeah you can't just
go to war because yeah because these are
just they're people if it was just like
blue Angry people who want to just like
go fight and stuff and they'll stay off
my Lane like that's the different
conversation not saying this right I'm
just saying it's a different Association
versus when you're seeing like no
there's there's real families here
people who probably have nothing to do
with the fighting yeah you know yeah and
I mean yeah it would have been cool to
spend time with you know all the levels
of society yeah but I think they do
communicate it well enough for when
she's flashing back and she's seeing
their people and her people together you
know in that Montage it it checks it
reads
um the parallel is there it's presented
do you think we can see Prince t'challa
and storm marrying in the future maybe
that would be fun yeah it's a Kevin
[ __ ] answer for you maybe articles
headlines Kevin feige says it's possible
if wakanda forever in the mutants show
make enough money then sure
um Clint and teriano hey guys have you
heard about the chosen being released
November 18th no but I know about Glass
Onion being released on the 23rd I'll
sign up for that what is the chosen is
this is this a Karate Kid spin-off The
Chosen The Chosen I gotcha with a zed
multi-season series about the Life of
Christ oh the free show tens of millions
of people who won't stop talking about
it oh I think we got reached out to
about this one oh they did reach out to
us
[Music]
maybe we'll check it out on our own time
and then do it controversial review
tearing this Jesus story apart I think I
know someone who works on it dude call
him up
get him on the stream yeah pretty sure I
do a guy named Jordan
that's a good name for a Biblical
project raccoon shampoo how much longer
do you see MCU continue on for will it
end when fights retires when foggy
retires if I he retires when there are
no more fights then the MCU will be done
um well I think the MCU doesn't have any
plans to ever end because
it is kind of strange you know because
some of these long-lasting franchises
like even like a doctor who or a James
Bond there's
longer breaks between them um
whereas the MCU requires
like a variety you have to keep up with
and I think that's why they've been
making kind of an effort to not make you
feel like you have to watch every single
one well because yeah once you're like
30 movies deep it's a little tricky
because it's not a franchise you got to
keep that in mind it's it is a franchise
but it's it's more than that it's a
studio it's an actual movie studio that
would be like how long do you think
Warner Brothers gonna continue which is
a good question but uh how hot do you
think like Disney's gonna get you all
for it it's because it's there are
Studios so the the corner the Marvel
Cinematic universes put themselves into
US It's gotta be all Marvel like that's
the one corner of it that still that
amalgam universe and they've established
themselves as everything's connected so
um yeah I think it's just they'll have
to keep evolving and adapting and and uh
changing it now but I don't think they
ever plan on ending at least it only
ends when they when they egregiously
stop making any money like no matter how
many people yeah yeah it's like if Kevin
fight I'm sure Kevin feige will have a
successor I am sure that the Universe
like as long as there are Marvel movies
the MCU exists and uh yeah like it'll
it'll go until it's not profitable nerdy
by Nature thank you so much yes love you
too buddy we are thankful for all that
you do in being here and being kind all
right let's make sure are we all caught
up so I think we got uh we gotta take a
little breather and then maybe film this
new rock stars reaction yes in the
morning
in the Morgan
Morgan
you know what I was just listening to
was the Pretty Fly for Rabbi that we
used to be very obsessed we're now
Pretty Fly for a rabbi all right guys
well um let's see here uh yeah I think
we will get into more solo project but
we're gonna end this stream thank you to
all who joined us
um yeah we're just gonna we gotta watch
this new rock stars we had 40 minutes
that is let's release it as as 10 minute
installments yeah yeah over the next
four days no we record how how can we
watch new rock stars live it's clearly
with all the editing and on the pauses
that we do you can't just do that live
set up multiple cameras yeah switchboard
yeah I know that that takes some time
yeah but uh thank you guys so much for
being here before you head out if you
hit that like button that'd be really
appreciated
um and hey I'm glad to talk about this
and a lot most people enjoyed it at
least it popped up on our stream we're
talking all soon thank you very much be
well